Welcome back, master and princess.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello.
Hi, Minky.
Hiya, Minto.
Hello, Minto.
Hello, Minky.
Hello, Minky Phantom Channel.
Hello, everybody.
Oh my gosh.
This is it.
Today is the finale.
The final battle of Devil May Cry 3.
Yippee!
This is the day we will...
I actually don't quite remember how many...
I was like, thinking earlier today, I was like...
I have five levels left?
I have four levels left?
I have five levels... I don't quite remember.
So, we're just gonna...
We're just gonna rock it, baby.
We're just gonna...
We're just gonna fight, fight, fight.
However many levels we've got.
Until we...
Win.
Today might be a bit of a longer stream, since it's...
Endurance to the end.
However many times it takes to beat the final boss.
Or any bosses.
Who knows?
Did you know this game was originally going to be DMC2?
But the last minute they realized they made that game once and no one liked it.
And everybody cried.
Time to fill his dark soul with light.
Will you play Vergil next stream?
What?
Like this game again, but as Vergil?
Or...
Well, I don't plan on it.
I was just gonna go into DMC4.
So, maybe someday in the future.
But no guarantee, I don't have any plans on it.
But, you know.
You could try him.
We could try him.
Is it the whole game again?
But as Vergil?
Or is it like a shorter version?
Halo, thanks for the gifted!
Thank you so much!
It's basically easy mode.
It's a little different.
It's easy mode though, because Vergil is so powerful, right?
I'm also powerful.
I can punch now.
And I got his fists.
We're fine.
But I imagine it has to be... It's the whole thing just without cutscenes.
But the cutscenes are so fun!
The cutscenes are so fun!
I wonder maybe if I could do like...
Doomguy!
Thank you for the Haka Super!
Have you made those devils cry yet?
Devils never cry!
Wait, but devils may cry.
Thank you so much!
I was gonna say, maybe we could do a stream where I go as far as I can as Vergil.
But I think I would do it probably after I beat the series, right?
It's just 4 and 5 left, so...
Unless I ever do DMC Devil May Cry.
Heads up, be careful with chat when playing DMC 4 and 5.
There's a lot to spoil and people will assume it's common knowledge.
Yeah, I...
We have a system.
I guess maybe some people don't know.
We have a system on this channel for when there are spoilers.
We have the smiley face system, as you can see.
Some people are already implementing it!
So, if you ever see a spoiler on the chat, you do the smiley faces.
Because 1, it helps push the message off the screen.
And then 2, it also kind of indicates to me, like...
Oh, I see a bunch of smileys.
I'm not gonna look at chat because a bunch of people are smiling.
Which means I might accidentally see a smile...
Not a smile.
I might see a smile.
But I might see a spoiler.
So, it has kind of two purposes.
I think it's my most brilliant invention ever.
Greetings from Poland!
I collect people trying to spell my name.
Spell?
Well, it's spelled right there for me.
Do you mean, like, say your name?
My name?
I can attempt...
Yeah, okay.
Okay,
let's get into the game!
Where's the audio?
Is it here?
Wait, why can't I hear anything?
Oh, that's why.
There we go.
We're good, we're good.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Hello ghost, hello.
Alright, last time watching this cutscene.
Oh my gosh.
So-called legend.
Oh yeah.
He also...
He also fucks, apparently.
He has sons!
That's like thinking about Goofy, you know?
I don't want to think about it.
Shoutout to my boy, Jake.
For how great of a devoted fan he is by waking up at 4 AM.
Of Perth, Australia.
I thank you, Mint, for being there with him.
Oh, it's just Jay, sorry.
Good morning.
Where's Mint?
Mint, where are you?
I love how...
He's too stiff.
I'm not gonna say that, that I said last time though.
I learned my lesson.
Thanks for getting Mint-ovated.
Oh wait, no, time to get Mint-ovated.
Thanks for bringing him, thank you!
Devil may cry.
Yay!
Alright, let's load our game, baby.
I don't know if you actually saw how Sparta looks like.
He does...
Fug.
Don't call him that.
You don't say that.
Don't call him fugly.
That's so mean.
Don't say that.
Ok, I'm guessing this is the one.
Alright, mission 15.
Clear, so we have 4.
Because there's 20.
I knew it was 3 or 4.
He did score Virgil's mom.
And Dante's?
20 minus 15 equals 5.
We're on 16.
Oh wait, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
Ok, let's just...
Load.
What did I press wrong?
This one.
Yes, load successful.
Load!
Load the game!
Oh, I accidentally pressed...
Ok, just kidding.
Ok, this is...we have to look for 16 everybody.
We're glitching out!
Oh no, I hate these guys.
Please spare me.
No, please.
I'm looking for 16.
That's my sweet...what?
What?
Where was it?
The gun flash?
I didn't see it at all.
In the gun flash, I was going blind and they expect me to see it?
What the hell?
Ok, let's check again how many rorbs we got.
16,000 rorbs.
Ok, Beowulf.
We can afford the straight too.
We got the air hike.
I've been using rebellion pretty consistently.
I switch between rebellion and agony sometimes.
Agni Rudra.
We could also get the jet stream too.
An air hike on here?
No, we can't get an air hike on here.
I'm a liar.
Glad to hear you considering DMC Devil May Cry.
I'd recommend playing between 4 and 5 as 5 has funny responses to the design choices of DMC's El Exterminador de Demonios.
Have fun.
Thank you.
Let's just get into it.
And see...wait, wait, wait.
What can we buy in terms of...
Nothing.
We can buy no blorbs.
We can buy no porbs.
So sad.
Ok, we are going to be right into it, aren't we?
Hold on.
It's my birthday!
Happy birthday!
Why does it have no name?
It's anonymous.
Hold on.
I'm learning how to play the game again.
One second.
I saw those guys.
Where did they go to?
Ok.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear anonymous.
Happy birthday!
Ok.
Gone.
Attack.
Alright.
Did we just open this?
Shoot you guys.
I can't remember what the hell happened last time.
We have the play button and the pause button.
We are going down.
Why can't I remember anything that happened last time?
Oh, whoops.
Why can't I remember anything?
Map?
Bad memory?
Clearly.
Ok, we opened this up.
We opened this up last time.
We went a bunch of places.
The map is useless.
Yeah, I'm kind of feeling that way.
I'm going through the red door.
I'm going back through the red door.
How do I... Gosh, why am I so...
What's wrong with me today?
Sorry.
Hold on.
I'm getting my bearings.
What the... Ok.
We're here.
Alright.
Ok.
Oh shoot.
Dang, guys.
Everything is so mysterious.
There is still somebody.
Sorry, am I ignoring you?
Are you lonely?
Stinger!
Oh.
Oh, this looks new.
What is this?
He who pursues the Onyx Moonshard makes all the spheres.
What?
Ok.
I'm on top of the ball.
Do I hit it?
What the hell am I doing?
Oh wait.
Do I need to break these?
Wait, what was... Hold on.
Or...
He who pursues the Onyx Moonshard makes all the spheres.
Do I have to combine them?
Alright, guys.
The balls must touch.
The balls touch, right?
That will make them whole again.
No.
Ok.
No!
Not hot dogs!
Didn't mean to donate anonymously.
No!
Thank you for the... Sorry.
Yuko didn't have to donate so much again.
Oh my gosh.
Please, Dante.
Ok.
Alright.
Hit.
Oh nice.
Good one, good one.
Forward now.
What?
Ok.
They are rocking.
Rocking balls.
Ok.
Now, you over here.
Also.
Rock.
Momentum!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
This is not very good.
That was good.
Please don't go up.
We were so close.
No breakdown.
That's what I'm gonna have trying to get these...
I am doing the right thing, right?
The balls need to touch, right?
That's the correct thing?
Ok.
And... Hit!
Hit!
Please, please.
Hit the balls.
Oh my gosh.
I don't even have these.
I don't know how to use them.
Ok.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Why don't they keep enough momentum?
Go!
Hit!
Please!
Please hit!
Oh my gosh.
Please!
No!
Maybe a different weapon would be better.
What a time to join the stream.
Welcome!
Thanks Chips for the superchat.
Maybe...
I don't know.
I don't think punching them would help.
Oh my goodness.
Ok.
Agni and Rudra?
Ok, ok.
Am I allowed to have more than one Vtuber Kamiyoshi?
Wait.
I think it's all up to however you wanna enjoy stuff.
Holy moly!
Oh my god!
It was so easy for them!
What the hell?
Why was it so easy?
Onyx Moon Shard.
A sculpture etched in the shape of an onyx moon.
It contrasts the golden sun sculpture.
I knew it.
I was gonna say, now we are gonna get trapped in here.
Right?
Who's here?
Oh my god.
No!
No please!
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
No, please.
Oh my god.
I'm wasting my DT.
I'm absolutely wasting my...
What was the best thing to do for these guys?
God!
You stupid bastard!
Ow!
Nice dodge.
Oh, ouch.
Oh my god.
I hate these guys so much!
Stop Dante!
These guys are the actual worst.
Oh my god.
Oh please.
Let me out.
Maybe...
Ice, baby.
Ice would be better.
Yeah!
Chew on this!
It's cool!
Yeah!
Chew on this!
It's cool!
It's not cool.
Yeah!
It's cool!
Oh my god.
Where are you?
You're in the ground?
Hello?
Oh my god.
Meow!
Oh, that was close.
Oh my god.
Please!
You too!
Can I...
Yeah!
Chew on this!
Ouch!
Fist them.
Should I try Beowulf instead?
Go to hell!
Ouch!
How am I supposed to...
Oh my god.
I don't know if I'm gonna make it, you guys!
I don't know how to beat this!
I don't know how to use Beowulf at all.
I'll try anything!
At this point!
Please!
No, Dante!
Why are you in the wall?
Please just die!
I'm in time.
So are they!
Dante!
Why are you in the wall?
Oh my god.
Get out of the...
I think I killed... No, I'm just kidding.
I thought I did.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna die because of your stupid ass!
I just started the game!
I don't want to touch the balls again!
At least Agni and Rudra made it really easy though.
Oh my god.
One HP in a dream, real?
How am I still alive, baby?
I'm just gonna keep punching them.
Golly!
Oh, ok.
Alright.
Nevermind.
Ouch!
Can you get out of the wall, you son of a bitch!
Oh, I tried dodging that.
I really did.
Nice.
Good job, Dante.
Oh, no!
Come on.
Get out of the wall.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna become the Joker for real.
Please!
Just die!
Oh god!
I hate these guys!
Get
out of the wall!
I love when they take collateral damage.
I hate
these guys more than anything!
Just punch his ass!
Oh my god!
Nice.
I hate that there are no I-frames in this game.
Like there are, but you know what I mean.
I get hit and I'm immediately comboed because this game is fucking ass!
Fuck you!
You stupid ass, stupid angels!
Oh my god!
Go!
Why don't you give me health, you stingy!
Also, hi Cinder!
Cinder, don't look!
You're seeing... I'm usually...
I'm usually OK.
It's just these guys.
They suck.
I just spit my tea all over the players.
Hold on.
I'm cleaning up my...
Ew!
I have a towel.
Hold on.
I was so...
But I still kept going even when I had something in my mouth.
OK, we got that Onix, moon Onix shard.
Let's go.
Let's get the heck out!
Oh no!
Oh, sheesh.
You too.
Don't attack me.
Can we switch to you?
No.
Switch to you.
Can we switch to you?
No!
Stop jumping away!
Two on this.
OK.
Let's go to this guy instead.
Nice!
I remember that thing.
That move saved my butt.
And that one boss...
Drinks tea angrily.
I did!
Holy moly.
Alright.
This is...
This is where we came from.
Where are we?
This is where we went and got the shard.
This is...
We came through the red door.
And then... What's this door?
I'm gonna punch him.
Before they start making more guys!
Oh gosh.
No, no, no.
That's not what I meant to do.
I meant to...
Do this.
Oh gosh.
Go to heal!
Kill him!
Kill his ass!
Take him down!
Leave no survivors!
Nice!
We actually did that.
You!
Yeah.
One
more.
Please!
I'm gonna...
Do this instead.
There are so many guys.
I feel like I should...
Thank you!
Idiot!
I was like, oh you are gonna jump huh?
I got you in the air!
Devil star!
I've been in here before, haven't I?
I do remember...
This is where the other ball was that I had to defeat.
I'm a little late.
You got this, Mito.
Thank you, Casey!
No worries.
I started so early today.
I guess we are farming roars, which is kinda nice.
Not if I can help it!
We got fancy stuff.
I should double kill him.
Nice.
Take this guy out.
Nice!
So good.
Come on!
Die already!
No!
No, no, no!
Stop him.
Stop his combo.
Okay.
Alright.
We can go back through now.
Now we go to the blue door.
Let's kill.
What was I getting these for, though?
I can't remember at all, you guys.
No, no, no!
There we go.
Nice!
Yeah.
I love Stinger!
Thanks for saving me the time.
Oh, a roar.
I almost missed.
Nice hit.
Let's take care of that.
No, no, no!
This one!
The immediate one right in front of me!
No, this one!
Oh god!
This one!
Just take him out!
While you can!
Maybe I didn't need to do that actually, but it's okay.
Oh please.
Just take him out!
Oh gosh.
It's okay.
No, no, no!
Don't hit them!
Okay.
Can I get this one?
This one instead.
He is right here.
Okay.
Oh shoot!
Shoot!
Not you!
You!
Okay.
One at a time!
Nice!
Okay.
I think that's all of them.
I'm just gonna punch you.
I'm just gonna...
Oh, cool.
And I'm gonna punch the other guy that's over here.
Where are you?
You're here?
Yeah.
He's almost donezo.
Oh!
It's tough when you have to like mix them up, you know?
It's just like, okay, I'm gonna shoot these guys, take down these guys.
I guess I could've taken down the guys.
But I'm just... I'm just... I'm just a ghost, okay?
Doing my best.
Alright, that was from the puzzle we did before.
So now we go through the door?
I'm out of breath.
Waking Sun Chamber.
I can't see anything.
What is this?
He who pursues the eternal power of the golden sun, release me from the darkness.
You?
Which way?
Which way do you swing?
Oh, I think I just have to release you from the thing.
I just have to break it, I think.
I thought I was trying to break the wall.
We did it.
Nice.
The golden sun.
A sculpture etched in the shape of a golden sun.
It contrasts the onyx moon shard sculpture.
It looks delicious.
Please, no.
God, please no more angels.
What the hell is that?
What the hell is this?
What is this?
Watch out, watch out.
Dante.
Interesting.
Ok, he goes down.
I got him.
I don't know how to play chess.
Oh gosh.
Oh gosh, Dante.
I'm gonna DT again.
The horse.
Oh my god, seriously, the worst timing.
Watch out, watch out, watch out, Dante.
I would much rather face these though than even one angel.
Angel.
The horse is...
Oh gosh, I'm always stuck in a combo.
And I can't get out before they start.
Let's do maybe this instead.
More?
Start blasting.
Oh my gosh, Dante.
Oh...
Good airline for a trip to Japan.
I think it really depends on...
What you're kinda trying to get out of your airline.
I think like Zip-Air or whatever is supposed to be pretty good if you want a really cheap trip.
You just have to bring your own food.
B-Y-O-F Ahem.
Okay.
Bionic Hippo, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Let's get out of here.
Living statues no more.
I leave, I leave, I leave.
Now I have the two things.
And I'm just gonna run for it.
I can't see.
Okay, bye.
Sun and moon chamber.
Now I have them for this.
The door is firmly sealed.
The two holes are collars into the door.
The sun and moon crest are etched above the door.
And go this way.
And open up.
The orange and banana.
Ice guardian.
That doesn't sound very good.
I can't see.
What is here?
Oh, screw this.
I hate.
I hate everything.
I HATE EVERYTHING.
I got him.
I got him just in time.
Wait, I don't think I...
Ah, there's also an... Oh my god, I can't believe you're here too.
Oh, wait, I did it again.
I'm such a dummy.
I'm such a...
Dumb.
Dumb, dumb, dumb.
No, get away.
This is not your fight.
Gosh.
Stop
your ass.
Oh my god, I can't see.
I can't.
What the hell is going on here?
Oh, please.
I can't.
I can see that.
Oh my god, this is the worst camera angle in the world.
No.
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm only just yelling today.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm a little stressed by this game, if you couldn't tell.
Holy moly.
Any hidden orbs anywhere?
I didn't like this part at all.
I wish this to never be...
Why do they keep... Why do they keep... Why do they keep doing this to us?
Oh my god.
No!
You son of a bitch!
You son of...
No, no, no.
Please send me back.
I'm running.
I'm leaving.
I'm running!
Endless Infernum is right.
Thanks for the salt.
Holy cow.
How's my health doing any...
That's not what I meant to do.
That's okay.
What the heck is this?
Artemis.
A gun of the demon world that discharges arrows concentrated with demon energy.
It's not a...
No way.
No way!
No, please.
It's the doors right here.
It's fine.
No, no, no.
I have to go back up.
No!
Oh my god.
What do you mean Minto?
How was I supposed to know?
I didn't know!
Get me out of here!
Get me out!
Get me up!
Okay, I'm just going to run past these guys.
Wait, what's over here though?
Anything?
No?
Okay.
Don't fall down.
Understood.
Okay, what does this say?
Nothing.
I'm illiterate.
Okay, into the door!
It's a long chapter.
Oh no.
Oh, I'm in here now!
This is where we fought the worm!
Oh gosh.
Oh no, no, no.
Run, run, run, run.
What's the purple smog?
Five!
Guys, I think I'm lost.
A centipede.
Sorry, I called it a worm.
I'm going the right way?
Okay, I'll trust you.
Surely, I won't get one guy.
I can't see anything.
I love running into the darkness.
How many...
18,000.
I really didn't get that much.
Felt like I farmed forever.
Okay, well...
It's straight.
Good.
Hold on.
I'm holding my drink.
A stinger, but with my fist?
I prefer staff.
Lunged forward and punched the enemy upward into the sky.
Stinger, but shorter.
We'll still save for now.
Oh gosh, I hurt.
What the heck?
Thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Lady!
Shut up.
It's her papa.
Her motivation.
Us too though.
Did you forget that we're also...
We also have family in here?
Yeah, we're not your enemy.
Why can't we work together?
Wait.
No way.
The books.
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me right now?
Oh shoot.
Lady, we can talk this through.
Oh god!
Get ready for what?
Ok, hold on.
Where are you?
Where did you go lady?
Hide and seek.
I also got guns.
Oh my god.
My stinger.
This music.
It's so funky.
Where'd she go?
Oh there she is.
She's trying to find me.
I'll see her though.
Come around the corner.
There she is.
Oh wow.
How could you miss?
Maybe trickster would be good here.
She's got such sass.
Oh my gosh.
She's so good at dodging.
Get ready.
These guys instead.
Ok.
Come on, wimp.
I hate this map.
Oh my god.
Oh my... Oh you...
I can't... I can't... I don't know where you are.
This sucks.
My new gu... Oh yeah, that's right.
I got a new gun, didn't I?
Get ready.
Why did I do that?
Dodge!
I
could not use that.
Damn, this thing is good.
Oh my god.
What's happening?
Where are you?
I can't tell anything at all.
I'm using this to heal.
Oh my god.
And it's gone now.
Oh shoot.
I am using trickster.
What are you talking about?
Oh my goodness.
Get down from there.
They are grenades.
Oh my gosh.
I can't even tell what she is doing because this map is shit.
Oh yeah.
Come on, please.
Oh god.
Come down.
Is this phase 2 technically?
Like where she doesn't drop down stairs anymore?
There is a higher ground.
I'm trying to... I'm trying to find her.
Oh my gosh.
She is so fast.
Can she...
She takes a lot of... She eats my damage.
What the hell are those?
Maybe I can get her now though.
Oh my god.
Die you!
Come here!
Come here lady!
Yeah, I'm a little bit scared lady.
Oh my god!
OK.
Now that I know how she works...
We got this.
Wait.
Oh, that's right.
She is right there.
OK.
I was like, wait a second.
Alright, let's skip.
And we are gonna do... I like these guys here.
She is coming.
Run after her!
No!
Am I on a trickster?
Trickster.
Oh shoot!
Shoot!
No!
Oh my god.
She is...
OK.
And I run too.
Running around.
Where are you at?
Lady!
Get ready.
Oh my god.
That was a close one.
I can never get her in time.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
No!
Come here!
My rage.
Huge damage baby!
Come here!
I don't...
Sorry.
Where are you going?
Oh, I heard her.
Nevermind.
I heard...
I heard her though.
I didn't.
Yeah, there she is.
Yeah!
Big damage!
And...
I forgot I wasn't on sword.
Are you still there?
Nice.
It's over.
OK.
Where did she go?
Nice.
She's so fast.
Come here!
With your nimble legs!
Lady!
So close.
There we go!
Just a little bit at least.
Oh my God.
Where is it coming from?
I don't know where it's coming from.
I found it.
No!
I'm not eating anything.
I'm full.
I've had my fill.
Thank you Lady.
Goodbye!
Oh my God.
Why couldn't her aim be like that while I'm fighting her?
Dante!
Why do you care so much?
Oh my gosh.
Dante, no!
Sorry guys.
I think it's the coffee that I had that's making me all like...
I'll stop drinking it.
Oh my gosh.
I think it's...
It's not that it's a regular coffee.
I got an espresso and it's making me...
Oh man.
I'm like...
I'm like crazy shaking.
Come on.
We can work together.
Why don't you...
No way.
A kiss.
I love
in these types of games.
It's always like a violent fight that just brings you together, you know?
Almost killing each other really just increases the bond.
Where are we gonna put this?
I don't have a pocket big enough for this gun.
Those are dumb shonen rules.
So true.
Wait.
Tell us your real name.
Maybe she likes going by lady.
Aww, lady.
Aww, lady!
My name is Adamska.
Kalina Anne.
A gun with lady's mother's name etched into the handle.
It has various...
I did not read that as uses.
And I almost read it again as the same thing.
I thought it said various issues.
I was like dang.
She's got a lot of issues, man.
Kalina Anne.
That's so pretty.
Gosh, this chapter is so long.
We have all the guns.
Yippee!
I was gonna say there was a gun we missed though, wasn't there?
But I'm thinking of DMC2 if I...
I think so.
I remember this area.
Oh,
Dante!
Dante, grab on!
Hyper Minto is best Minto.
Sorry, it's really the Espresso.
Yeah!
Mission clear!
40 minutes!
Captain Aminto is extra silly and cute.
Oh!
I forgot to save.
That's one freaky Espresso.
I think it was an Espresso.
Pretty sure.
It was like an Espresso shot in it.
I just wanted to try it because it sounded yummy.
It's not actually that great.
It's okay though.
Welcome to my workshop.
Thank you.
Boo, Baldi.
Boo, you wish you were as cool as Volgin.
You're just a skinny guy.
He's got our necklaces.
His face.
Wow, it didn't even leave a scratch.
I think this is bad news bears.
I think this might be a bad thing.
Mission 7.
Oh, I missed it.
Was it in the trees?
Inner Demons, confront your shadow.
Almost 30.
We could get more DT.
Might be good to have.
Oh, the pillars.
I'm gonna go find a cutscene compilation that shows where all the numbers are.
I don't know.
Let's just go into it.
Let's just see what we got first.
What's going on and then we'll figure it out.
I like to see what's going on first before we purchase anything.
Cashew, thanks for the raid.
Thank you.
We came from here, so let's go this way.
Nice.
No Roar was hidden from me.
Oh gosh.
I think I tried to get this one before.
Nice.
OK.
Thanks for the gift.
What is this?
What am I fighting?
Oh god.
Wait, is this that one room that they don't stop coming until...
Oh my god.
Why would I need to go back there?
Ducky, thanks for the gifted!
They don't stop coming.
Yeah, I didn't do that room because...
Maybe it would be easier now with all the new weapons we got.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Everything is twisting and turning.
Oh no.
No, please.
I already have bad depth perception.
Don't do this to me.
Oh my goodness.
Rorb farm.
What are the Rorbs?
Like what are they made of?
And the Blorbs.
Like why do they have human faces?
Seven?
Anyway, I moved forward.
Forward.
We went real.
This is where Air Raid on Nevin really shines.
Dang it.
But we do have an Air Raid.
I guess I went the harder direction.
OK.
Nice, nice, nice.
Alright.
I cannot see.
What is this door?
First of all...
We have our first door.
Oh god.
Stop parrying me!
I like this thing a lot though, honestly.
I feel like it works pretty well to also like make it so that...
Oh my god.
So that if something is also trying to hit me...
It's harder to parry though.
But it's like there's things behind me and stuff trying to get me too.
I can at least... Oh my goodness.
OK.
Maybe I give up.
Maybe I lied.
No, that's not what I meant to do.
What is this?
Holy cow!
Did that hit me too?
There's splash damage?
Oh there is no... Oh, he just hit me?
OK.
That'd be so funny.
It'd be so funny if there is.
I'm turning it down.
Oh my gosh, it's so loud.
I feel like I'm screaming at you guys.
Which way did I come from?
That door.
Oh, we're here!
What boss was in this room?
I don't remember.
Wait, no, this is where I got Agni and Rudra.
Yeah, that's who was in there.
Oh, how fitting that we...
That we defeated them then with it.
Kalina Ando's crazy damage, doesn't it?
Are you guys 100% sure there's no splash damage?
100%?
You're not lying to me?
What's this?
Lord Fragments.
Wow, lucky!
Let's go.
No splash.
OK.
Thank you.
No joke.
You're joking?
You're joshing me?
Is that all that's here?
You know what?
It's kind of worth it.
Go through the fight for the blorb.
There's really nothing here?
No, there has to be.
Right?
No help.
OK.
So I'm missing something.
You guys are saying I'm missing something.
OK.
I love this game a lot.
This section is not one of the reasons.
Good luck platforming, Minto.
Thank you.
Oh, really?
Up you go.
OK.
Lucky.
Thanks for letting me not waste my time, guys.
I do appreciate that, actually.
I'm not being sarcastic in the slightest.
Oh no!
Eirik.
OK.
Don't do that.
Don't do that, please.
Shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
It's alright.
We can get there.
Pretty easily, I'd say.
OK, nice.
Oh, what?
I jumped out.
I did.
Maybe something was blocking me and I didn't see it.
I did jump.
Wait a second.
Oh, nevermind.
No, nothing was blocking me.
I'm just an idiot, I suppose.
Oh, OK.
I'm assessing my next move.
I don't want to go on top of those.
Maybe this one that's going in a little circle right here.
Don't push me off, please!
Don't push me off!
You!
I want...
OK, that's not...
I am...
Eirik, thank you for the superchat.
Suffering.
OK, we went on to...
That ride right there.
I can't see!
Jump for the beef.
I am, I am.
Oh, OK.
This guy only goes up and down.
I'm just going back here then.
I'm not going to waste my time.
This one.
This one, like, dancing around.
Right here.
This one!
This is the one I want.
Oh gosh.
Please, please.
Please!
OK, OK.
Come by with this tower.
Made me cry as a kid.
No way!
So close.
OK.
We are close.
And...
Run!
OK, I'm dancing in the air.
I don't...Where do I go from here?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna...
Guys, I think...
I made a mistake.
I can't see!
What's going on?
No!
Oh no, please!
Dante use your arms for once!
Dancing, platforming, my not beloved.
Luckily, to get to where we were at is not very difficult.
Like so?
Maybe I try...nevermind.
You know what?
Let's try a different way, right?
No!
Do I not see the stairs?
I don't see anything, honestly.
The camera is really bugging me out.
OK.
I think there is one that descends all the way down here.
Yeah, this one.
OK.
And then it goes up.
And it goes higher.
And we can go here.
People are saying these stairs, right?
OK, jump.
No!
How are you supposed to...
How are you supposed to get out of that when it blocks you out?
Truths welcome to...Mabusha, thank you!
Oh, from the right side.
OK.
VOD watchers...
VOD watchers, skip...
Another 45 minutes.
Oh, Truths!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the 20 gifted!
What the heck!
Thank you so much, I really appreciate it.
Alright, here we go.
Skip to February.
OK, so we go over...
To here.
And then I jump onto it from here.
Please...No!
No!
We made it!
OK, OK, OK.
Don't skip!
Don't...
Don't skip 40 minutes!
You'll miss it!
Don't skip!
Is this the Jonkler guy again?
Too late, I skipped.
No!
Can I get around him?
See ya!
He's like, you really wanna fight me, don't you?
What are we fighting here?
Oh, it's these guys.
OK, actually...
Oh my god, I can't see when you...
Come on!
Nice!
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
You know what it was worth?
Because we were able to get one guy.
Nice!
That was good.
We got really lucky with that.
Hey!
Oh, it's this room!
You start as a baby...
And then you...Oh shoot.
Wait, there's only two ways we can go.
Never skip Minto Day or...Oh!
Just kidding!
There's only one way I can go!
Trial of skill.
Oh, it's this one again.
That's right.
What's on the other side?
What am I...
We have air hike.
OK.
Alright, run!
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh, I made it?
Nice!
We made...Oh gosh!
We made it?
Alright, let's go.
Upwards.
Pitch black void.
They keep calling it that.
I literally can see everything.
Over name this sucks.
More hidden robes for me.
Every minute skipped is when you can't stare at me.
Why would you want that?
Why are you doing that, you freak?
OK.
I think that's all of them.
OK, 38.
I was like, wait a second, I only have 3000?
Hello?
Oh no!
I'm not running.
I'm shooting whatever.
I can't see anything.
I'm assuming this is working.
Cerberus, yeah, because they are icy.
Yeah, take that.
Dang, these guys are beefy.
Beef, beef, beef.
Oh, they are both down.
What am I doing?
Oh, Redman!
OK, nice.
Easy.
What's your devil trigger look like?
Or is it a ghost trigger?
Maybe a demon trigger.
Maybe one day you'll see it, I don't know.
GT, Dragon Ball.
Moonlight Mile.
This is where we fought who?
OK, what should I buy?
Revolver level 2.
Jetstream, I have so many things I could buy.
I don't really use Nevin.
I'm sorry, I really don't use Nevin.
We also have more for Beowulf.
No...
I know, right?
I use Revolver a lot.
So I was like, Revolver 2 would be good.
Revolver 2 is good.
I could buy...
Like, two things, honestly.
Maybe straight level 2.
Level 2.
Maybe straight level 2 and then...
Is Beast Uppercut good?
What was the...
How do I use it?
R, L, Back, X.
OK.
So it's basically my...
The one for Rebellion that I love.
Put your hand up!
It's really good?
I love seeing, it's meh.
And it's really good.
Right next to each other.
I don't think you would use it a lot.
Possibly.
Let's do straight level 2.
Oh, that's not what I meant.
Sorry.
Let's do straight level 2.
And let's do Cerberus level 2 as well.
I think... Wait.
That should be good for now.
I want to not spend all my money.
I don't want to spend all my money right now.
Virgil, you here?
What is that?
Should I skip you?
Raymack, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
Oh, did we get another raid?
Hello!
Thanks for the raid!
Wait, I didn't see who raided, but thank you!
Hello, hello.
OK, I'm going through.
Oh,
Arisu.
Welcome!
Thank you.
My shadow!
Oh my God, this really is Kingdom Hearts.
I don't know about that.
You don't need your shadow?
I don't think that's how that works, Dante.
You just get one.
You tell him.
Oh my God.
OK, that was good.
OK, great.
Do I need to get him into the light, I think.
Oh my gosh.
Where is the light?
OK.
Why are your tricks so much faster than mine?
Oh my God.
Where is the light?
Oh, here we go.
I see, I see, I see.
Yeah!
Oh, now you're just a little baby wimp!
Baby wimp, baby wimp.
Oh, he's destroying me.
Come and get me.
Where are you anyway?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, there's another one.
Oh, you're just so small!
You are such a tiny man!
Oh, that's not good.
I didn't mean it.
Oh no!
Yeah, when he comes and gets me, I can do this.
Dang it, I was too slow.
Come and get me.
You taught me, I taught you.
Oh!
Oh,
he says the same things as me!
That's so funny.
No!
Oh, dang it.
I was too early.
Come on, wimp.
Oh my God.
Oh, shoot.
It's not good, it's not good.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
Come on, wimp.
No!
I had that, I had that.
Oh, I had that, I had that, I had that.
Which one are you going aiming for?
Stop!
You're ruining my hard work.
Come on.
Maybe he'll come towards me now.
Dang it.
I can't time it right.
He keeps aiming for the same one.
Oh, shut up.
Same one again?
Oh my God.
Oh my God, that scared me.
Oh my God, it scared me so bad.
Oh, I couldn't even move.
Holy jump scare.
I don't think... Let's try a different weapon maybe.
Sheesh.
OK.
It's like the one thing that can ruin a game is audio balancing.
Beowulf might be best for the opening lights in one hit.
And I do have air hype with that, which... Oh my God, go away!
OK, so I can't do anything to him while he's...
This is so messed up!
What the hell?
I didn't even do anything.
Stupid!
Can you not go after... OK.
Which one did you go after?
Oh God, oh God, oh God, we're not gonna make it!
You son of a bitch.
Even still...
I'm not gonna use that anymore.
There we go.
Maybe, but he was kind of further away.
The stinger and that one hit, it works!
The stinger!
Hit!
Yeah, it's good.
OK, OK, OK, OK.
Oh, that was good, that was good.
That was good damage.
Wow, shoot!
Shoot, oh shoot.
No!
OK, OK.
Oh, we got him, nice.
OK.
Oh my God, I did not expect him to come after me again.
No!
Come and get me!
Which one?
Why did you do that?
It was already done!
We're so close.
Dang it, I didn't time that one well.
My bean.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God.
Don't taunt him.
Oh my God, don't taunt him.
He's serious.
Oh shoot.
Uh...
OK, maybe I can...
Nice shoot.
Oh, almost there.
Almost there.
Come on, ween.
No, no, that's not what I meant to do.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, come on, come on, Dante, one more, one more, one more hit.
Stop taunting.
Dante, Dante, please.
Dante, you're throwing.
OK, here we go.
No, so close.
Where is it?
Oh my God.
Come on.
There it is.
Please.
Oh my God.
I didn't fumble.
It was Dante.
I'm targeted on the right things.
Kingdom Hearts.
Oh yeah, my mirror image.
You can't trust literally anyone in the series.
You even have to fight yourself.
What the hell?
Doppelganger?
Special power used by the Doppelganger enemy.
This style gives you more freedom in battle to try out different tactics and combos.
Change styles to Doppelganger by quickly pressing the left button twice.
Oh, I think I did it.
I get a single roar before that.
Oh, my health.
If you had a friend while you used Doppelganger, a second joystick can press start and control the shadow.
Please.
Nice.
Save.
Alright, alright, alright.
That leaves three more missions.
What one are we on?
18?
18.
Shall we?
Why did they word it as if you had a friend?
They are saying, if you had a friend.
I missed it again.
Dang it.
I was too busy watching tiny Dante fly into the sky.
Break the seal and battle into the depths.
Fill your dark soul with light.
Oh,
my gosh.
Lord of the Rings Eye of Sauron is staring at us.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Gosh, I feel like royalty.
Oh, my God.
You guys all know who I am.
Thank you.
I don't know how to... Oh, my God.
No.
I don't think that's how you play.
I don't think that's how you play the game.
Ok, we'll get them to come towards... Oh, that's not what I meant.
I totally thought...
Run away.
Shoot them with my really big gun.
Oh, shoot.
Shoot.
Just do one at a time.
Get the small babies out of the way first.
Get the small babies out of the way.
Jump.
Small babies out of the way.
The big babies are coming in.
Wait.
Oh, I can only attack the ones that are light.
Ok.
Interesting.
So now I can attack him.
Oh, ok.
I can't attack you anymore.
But maybe in a second.
Maybe you'll... Undo?
No?
Oh, God.
Oh, the king.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
I can't see when you guys walk away like that.
What's happening?
The horse.
There we go.
Take him out.
Oh, my God.
Is that the queen?
Oh, the king is back.
Oh, my God.
Ok.
I don't think it pays to attack him.
Oh, gosh.
Who can I attack right now?
You.
Oh, what's going on?
What is happening?
Oh, my God.
Everything is craziness.
Only the queen is active at the moment.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
What the... I'm literally... Oh, God.
Ok.
Stop.
Oh, my God.
Run, run, Dante.
I think I'm gonna change to punching them.
Oh, my gosh.
Ok.
I forgot.
Sometimes I can punch you.
Sometimes I can't punch you.
Punch.
Run, Dante.
Oh, my God.
I'm about to die.
Run, run, run.
Ok, we got that guy out of the way.
I'm gonna die though for real.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna tank it.
I'm gonna...
Oh, thank God.
Oh, my goodness.
Wait, who is healing them?
You son of a bitch.
No way.
Run.
Oh, gosh.
This is so much.
There is just too much happening.
I can't concentrate.
There is so much happening.
Oh, my goodness.
I didn't even see that one happening.
Oh, my God.
As soon as I...
Just get rid of you.
Get rid of you.
They are laughing and I'm crying.
Thank goodness.
Is this one of the healing ones?
Ok.
Oh, my gosh.
Out of the way.
Who is laughing at me anyway?
So mean.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I thought you were...
Ok, besides the king...
He is going to sacrifice himself.
Oh, my goodness.
This is insanity.
Ok.
This is not how you play chess.
I don't think this is how you play chess.
Oh, this guy is still around.
Hey there, buddy.
Get my little hidden.
I got to get rid of this one of these things at least.
Oh, thank goodness.
No, I tried to jump away.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Oh, good.
I'm going to have to redo all of this again and I think I'm going to lose my...
Do I have any heals?
I don't want to do this again.
I do have a heal.
I hate chess.
I'll never play it.
I can't... I don't...
Maybe I could have saved it for a more serious...
I feel like this is a pretty serious situation.
To
defend yourself!
Oh, my God.
I can't see.
What just happened there?
I'm trying to hit you.
Oh, I forgot I'm a trickster.
Oh, my God.
Trickster level 2!
Hold L in any direction and press A while in mid-air.
Perform the dash maneuver two times in rapid succes...
Oh, my God.
Big news!
That was so good!
Oh, my God!
Demon chess is like chess.
Pawns transform if you let them cross the board.
Towers change place...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I'm just gonna run.
I'm just gonna leave.
Goodbye!
Sayonara!
Oh, my God.
They are fast.
Goodbye!
Grorb.
Grorb, I'm in desperate need.
Delicious.
Nutritious.
What the?
Oh, this is a world?
These are doors?
No.
Oh, no.
This guy again?
I don't remember how I killed him before.
I think I jumped up on the spider's back.
I mean the... What's his name?
Oh, wait.
That was great.
Good job.
Good job, Watashi.
There was an attempt.
Absolutely.
Did I get on him?
Yeah!
I got on him.
Alright.
Jump, jump, jumpy!
Just Cerberus for this one?
But then I don't have my airhike.
Okay, I'll try it.
He's coming up top.
I knew it.
Oh, gosh!
The parry, the parry, the parry!
Oh, we're just eating it.
Hold on.
Maybe this one will be better.
Maybe this one will be better for parry.
Yeah,
but only dashing the air is horizontal, not upwards.
Okay, here it comes, here it comes.
Oh, I'm eating, I'm eating it, I'm eating it.
How
I did this before?
Where is the purple coming from?
Oh, that's not purple.
Okay.
Holy moly.
Did I use Cerberus before?
Hold on, I'm waiting for him to...
We already got him halfway there.
Good thing we upgraded.
Oh my god, oh my god.
It's because I decide too late what I want to do.
Okay, purple.
Not purple.
No purple?
That's okay.
Oh, dang it.
He's doing the spin around.
He's going for the full tour.
I missed.
Okay, come on buddy.
Come on back.
Is it purple time?
No, it's blue time.
Oh, that's right.
These things still hurt me.
Oh.
So close.
Come on.
Oh, purple!
Let's go.
I was going to say, he doesn't give me anything.
He gives me some orbs.
I'll take it.
Alright.
Oh, oh, oh no!
They're going to disappear, aren't they?
Oh, I got him.
Alright.
Shiny.
Ah!
It does light up.
Thank you.
Later, Minto goes to a chess tournament and ends up defeating the game pieces and calls of the day, confusing the players.
Who's that guy that like had the controversy?
I can't remember what the controversy was either.
It was like...
They thought he had something up his butt.
And that it was like vibrating and giving him moves.
I forgot about that until this very moment.
Now I'm really upset that I remembered it.
Are all of these bosses?
And then also...
Do I have to do every single one of them?
Yes!
Alright, let's go to pink.
Oh, ma'am.
How did I defeat you before?
Oh my gosh.
I don't remember.
I think I just did this.
I just like got my DT up by shooting her.
This is a test of my memory.
Oh!
Oh my god.
We're getting our DT up.
How did I activate... Oh gosh.
I think she went in for the hug and I went in for the kill.
lol
Oh my gosh.
I love having double dash now.
Oh yeah!
Feels good.
And then... Oh!
Oh my god.
Ah!
Okay.
Alright.
I think I go in for the hug now.
That's like the easiest one to avoid too.
I'm so mad.
Uh...
Mito, you're not hitting.
I know!
I said I'm building up DT.
I'm trying to remember how to defeat her.
You guys!
You guys, seriously?
You guys, come on.
I said, okay, I shoot her to build up DT.
That's literally what I said.
And then you're all in chat being like...
You guys are in chat being like...
Oh!
You're not hitting her.
Yeah, I know.
The gun is short range?
That's so weird because it's a rocket launcher.
No hit equals no DT.
I know that sometimes I'm not always hitting, but...
Yeah, it's dumb.
lol
Just how it works.
Okay, well, I didn't know that it was a short range weapon, so...
You know, I guess that's my fault for not reading.
I guess it's always my fault.
It's always my fault.
I just won't use it.
And I am building DT.
You can literally see it building.
I'm gonna go get some more water.
I'll be right back.
Okie dokie.
Alright.
I don't remember how to beat her.
I'll figure it out eventually.
Or I'll just run in circles and make you guys even more angry.
lol
Why didn't she go in for the hug?
Sugar.
Oh, here she comes.
Oh, nevermind.
Oh, number.
Number.
What did I do to trigger her?
Is it gonna go far away?
Sugar.
Can't remember.
Oh, here we go.
I just have to hit her a bunch.
When did she do the hug though?
I don't know.
Ok, I'm just gonna go for her.
Come here lady.
Come here pretty lady.
Oopsie.
I'm getting greedy.
Getting greedy.
If I die, I die though.
Whatever.
Oh, madam?
Wait, where's the other stage?
Did it disappear?
Oh my god.
Ok, maybe she starts doing the hug now.
I don't remember.
Oh my god.
Oh my god lady.
Where's the other stage?
Is there not one?
Oh, it's right there.
I guess I was against the wall.
Ah, stupid VTuber.
She's so dumb.
She doesn't even know where things are.
Gummy VTuber.
She doesn't know anything.
Oh my god.
When are you gonna hug me?
Please.
I've been a good boy.
Please ma'am.
I need a hug.
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
I almost...
Oh my god.
I thought I was...
Oh, ow, ow.
Oh my god.
No!
Wait.
I don't have to start from the very beginning, do I?
With the yellow?
Where's the thingy?
Oh, there it is.
It won't let me jump in this area for some reason.
Oh, ok.
Yellow is still lit.
Okie dokie.
Let's go back to hot lady.
Just taking screenshots.
Now you will become hot.
Oh shoot.
I forgot that's what happened when she said that.
I love spamming gun.
Let's...
Ok.
Come here.
Come here ma'am.
You got one little pair of bats.
No, I won't become tired.
I'm wide awake.
Waste all your bats.
Oh, nice.
I'm killing your bats.
Get ready.
Sugar.
It's my favorite line.
Ma'am.
Up.
I forgot I didn't have air hike.
Pain, pain, pain, pain.
It's ok.
Come here.
Come here ma'am.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Not really.
I'm so bad at avoiding those.
There we go.
I will.
No, I'm not.
Why are you combining?
Oh my god.
I thought she would stop.
Sugar.
Come here.
Take it.
Take my ice.
Taking out your bats.
I'm taking out your bats.
No,
no, no, no, no.
I'm taking out your bats.
Taking out your bats.
Give me a hug lady.
I'm so lonely.
Get rekt.
Sugar.
Yeah, I love that part.
I forgot I had double dip.
I can't see.
Why are there so many bats on the side?
Oh, come on.
Oh my god.
Ah, sugar.
I'm not enjoying myself.
I'm just gonna let my DT go.
Because I don't have...
Because I need more health.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh.
Ah.
Sugar.
Come on lady.
Oh, come on lady.
Okay, maybe one, two more time.
Maybe.
Ah, sugar.
Oh, more hug.
Oh gosh.
Oh no.
Get me out.
I wanted the hug.
I asked for the hug all this time.
And then I blew it.
I blew it!
Oh my god.
I hate these ones.
They are scary.
Oh
my health.
My health.
I'm so scared.
Ah, sugar.
Get my DT up.
I'll play it cool.
I'll play it safer now.
Play it safer now.
No!
This is the least favorite one.
Oh shit.
Come on.
Get out Dante.
You stupid.
You stupid lady.
Oh my god.
Wait.
How did I get so much...
How did I lose so much health?
No.
I lost all the health.
I lost it all.
No.
Are you enjoying yourself?
Are
you enjoying yourself?
Are you enjoying yourself?
Oh my god.
Please Dante.
Okay.
I...
Fear.
I fear.
No.
Please.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm going in.
Come here man.
I'm attacking you.
Please.
There we go.
I was so close to beating you before.
I was so close.
I was just like one little thing away.
Please.
I was so close.
Oh my god.
You.
No.
This is it.
That's it.
I jumped.
Why does
it have to be a boss rush?
Why?
Why does it have to be a boss rush?
I'm already in a pissy enough mood.
We won't tell anyone you're doing it for the purpose to get a kiss from sexy demon lady.
Yeah, don't tell my secret, okay?
Come here lady.
You wish you were lady.
I actually just don't know your name.
And I don't care to learn it.
Sugar.
Come here.
Nevermind.
I was coming to you.
See, I lose health there.
So annoying.
Oh shoot.
I forgot that's what she did there.
I was not.
I gotta lock in.
Gotta lock in on the lady.
Lock in on lady.
Okay, come here.
Okay.
I'm sleepy.
I'm so tired.
Oh dang it.
Why?
Okay.
There we go.
Big damage.
No!
Not enough damage.
Okay.
The floor is lava!
Are you enjoying yourself?
Sugar.
Alright, come here.
I'm not hitting her at all.
The floor is lava!
No I'm not.
I hate this one.
Oh my god.
And then she spin.
No she don't spin.
She spin?
She don't spin.
Sometimes she spin.
Sometimes she don't spin.
And the floor is lava!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Stop spamming this.
Oh my god.
See?
This is so stupid.
Oh my god.
Lady.
Sugar.
Yeah!
Damage.
Not biggest damage though.
Could have been bigger damage.
Lady.
And the floor...
Is lava!
Oh my god!
Let me out of here first!
Sugar.
It doesn't matter if you get close to her or not.
Because it doesn't negate that attack.
You know what I mean?
Lava!
It doesn't make her stop doing it.
See?
Oh gosh.
It's so annoying.
I'm not...
I'm not enjoying myself.
Are you gonna spin?
Nope.
I thought I had her.
Oh my god.
Floor is lava!
What?
Did she spam this so much before too?
I don't remember her using this attack like...
Oh my god.
No!
Like exclusively.
I don't remember her spamming it so much.
She does spam it a lot?
Not done.
Lava!
Oh my god.
I just wanna get one...
Ah, shit.
There we go.
Come on!
Okay.
Is she trying to kiss me?
We got her kiss.
We got away from the kiss.
How do I get out of the kiss?
DT?
Oh my fucking god.
So mad.
I have to do this again.
Oh my god.
I tried dodging and it didn't work.
I'd be fine if it was like the final boss, you know?
In fact, I have to do all of them again.
Sucks so much.
And now she's back to phase 1.
I don't know if I should be grateful for her or not.
I don't even have any motivation.
I have no motivation!
No motivation!
Give
me my health back, please.
No, I really not.
I want my money back.
Lady!
I'm never frequenting this establishment ever again.
I never thought I would!
Okay, you're still going.
You go for such a long time.
You're so extra.
Oh my god, as soon as I try to get closer...
And then she's gonna say, are you enjoying yourself?
No!
Are you though?
Oh yeah, having a great time.
I'm so fucking dumb with this game.
No, god!
Fuck me!
No!
No, I'm not!
Okay!
Get my health back.
Getting my health back.
Getting DP back.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, again!
She's doing that!
Come on, wimp!
Okay.
Alright, and we attack, attack, attack, attack, attack...
Okay, we gotta save some DT though.
We gotta save some DT.
Okay.
Alright, shoot shooty shooty shooty shooty shooty shooty shooty shooty shooty shooty shooty shooty shooty.
Okay, come on.
ARGH!
Well, I-I did it.
I did escape.
Mwahahaha.
Come on!
Okay.
Oh,
wait.
I don't know why I-I did that.
I'm so used to just shooting her.
It's okay, we didn't have DT, so...
Alright.
Now we do.
So close, so close.
So close, so close, so close.
My health is good too.
But, you know.
Alright, let's see what next bastard we want to take down.
You're giving birth?
Congratulations.
I can't tell from this one.
Is this Beowulf?
Will I just cry?
Yes?
Okay, I save for later.
Maybe we should just do it though.
Get it out of the way.
What's this one?
Oh, this is the...
The sky.
We went inside his tummy.
The whale.
You don't need to kill all bosses to beat this.
You just need to make a circle using gems.
IDK why everyone says you needed to.
What?
I hate you guys.
Except...
Joe!
Joe...
Why do you guys...
Why do you guys want to see me suffer?
I hate you guys so much.
Joe mama.
Oh my god, why do you guys want to see me suffer?
Like this.
Why?
Okay.
My bad.
One second.
Devil Arms?
Cerberus?
What was the combo?
Is it this one?
No.
Satellite?
What's it called?
Oh good, I was thinking it was the five gifted.
Wait.
Swing?
No.
It's not Revolver.
It's the one where we create the ice.
Ice.
Ice Age?
I don't even see that in here.
Oh, Sword Master Style.
So I have to... Do I have to change my...
Oh god.
Oh, chew on this.
Ha!
Chew on this.
Cool!
Okay, let's go attack the...
No!
Oh, I forgot to Devil Trigger.
Oh, gosh.
I end.
Oh wait, no, no, no, no.
Continue.
Yes, oh my gosh.
I'm about to... I'm literally about to quit it.
Hold on.
Okay, so we gotta make a circle.
I thought this was the flying...
I didn't know it was actually the one in his stomach.
Okay.
So I have to make the circle.
So I... Okay, so I just don't get the ones on the inside like Beowulf and then the blue one.
So I just have to do everything else.
Any circle you want?
So it can even be a teeny tiny circle?
You can make any circle!
No way.
Oh, but...
If I make a tiny circle, I have to fight Beowulf.
But we could do...
What's green?
Let's go see and check out what green is.
This is...
I don't remember.
Oh, you guys!
I like fighting you.
I use you to fight you.
Wait.
Okay, hold on.
I'm remembering how to do this.
I think I wanna be Trickster.
Okay.
Oh, hold on, hold on.
I can't see anything!
I can't see!
The camera!
I
have no heads!
That's so sad.
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Oh, god.
Camera, camera, camera, camera, camera!
Camera!
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I'm such an idiot.
I keep forgetting I'm not in sword mode.
You know?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Only blue, only blue, only blue, only blue, only blue!
Actually, wait.
We get them both down.
That's right.
Hold on.
I remember.
We have to get them both down pretty low.
Otherwise they'll combine.
I remember.
Oh, come on!
Come on!
I used to beat them before.
I can't remember.
Oh,
no, no, no!
You bastard.
Server's guarantee is buried.
Is that true?
Oh, you... I went the wrong way.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Okay.
Let's focus on you again.
In fact, I'm gonna... Never mind.
Come here.
No, stop.
It's a window.
I can't see.
Oh, come on!
I'm such an ass.
Okay, he's down.
Now, servers.
Is it gonna...
So close.
Is it gonna enhance their health?
Since there's two of them.
Can you stop with the theatrics?
I've seen this part before.
Oh my god.
I was so close.
Oh my god, please.
Just fight back, Dante.
Just fight back.
Just fight back, Dante!
Did you see how much health he had?
Did you see that?
He totally should've been dead.
He should've been down.
Yeah, call the referee.
Ref, this guy is playing unfair.
I think I went down here.
We'll just fight him again, I guess.
I hate this so freaking much.
Okay.
I don't care who I focus on first.
I focus on someone.
I'm focusing on someone.
I'm focusing on anybody.
I don't really care right now.
Yeah, I'm focusing on you.
These guys are so much less annoying than the lady, though.
Doesn't matter if she's sexy.
Pisses me off.
Hot women aren't supposed to piss you off.
That's just not how that's supposed to go.
I tried to dodge.
Okay, you.
Alright, don't get him so down, though.
Don't get him so down, though.
Okay, should be good for now.
Come on.
Alright, red guy.
Red.
Oh, wow, that was so fast.
I wish I had any double trigger.
Double trigger.
Fast.
Fast as much as I can.
Okay, I need to get the other guys more, though.
Huge damage, I know, right?
Red.
Shoot.
No!
I'm too strong for my own good.
I won't let you skip this cutscene.
I can't control my...
I can't control myself.
Am I healing during all of this?
Or like... Is my double trigger just like...
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Ah, shoot.
Just keep going, Dante!
Just keep going!
Dante, don't stop!
Don't stop, Dante!
Don't stop the nunchucks!
Dante!
Dante, don't stop the nunchucks!
Don't stop!
What's the blue one?
The light blue.
Is there anything else down here?
Oh, a grower.
Thanks.
And... Is that it?
This is the dark blue.
Where's the light blue?
Oh, the light blue is the horse?
That one is so not bad.
Let's find it.
The horns.
Oh, light blue is probably Cerberus?
Well...
No, dark blue is horse.
Okay, that was the horse.
Well, do we want to do Beowulf again?
You know what?
Let's do the horse and Beowulf.
I don't care.
I don't care!
At least I know I'm getting myself out of here if I do Beowulf.
Beowulf.
How the hell did I do this before?
I just... I gotta find the horses back!
I think I'm just gonna start blasting.
Damn, he ran me over.
I don't
remember how the hell I did any of these fights.
What the hell is wrong with me?
Why don't I remember anything?
And then he teleports me and I...
That was a rhetorical question.
You don't need to say anything.
You don't need to be like, you're just bad at the game.
That was a rhetorical question.
You know, I need to pay attention.
Oh, Jesus.
I don't wanna fight any of these guys anymore.
I don't wanna do it anymore.
I don't mind.
You say worst bosses are yet to come, but I don't mind fighting new guys.
I'd rather much fight new guys than fight old guys.
Fighting old guys is the worst thing.
Like, I hate that.
I hate fighting bosses that I've already done.
Especially if it's the same exact fight.
I'm just gonna die here.
I don't...
Kill me, horse.
Kill me.
She hates old guys.
Cerberus is right here.
Maybe I should just do that instead.
Hey, buddy.
It's been a long time.
Oh, wow.
Wait.
Oh, I'm a trickster?
Oh, I'm not a trickster anymore.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm getting lost in the sauce.
I'm getting so lost in the sauce.
We're shooting.
We're rooting, tilting, shooting.
Oh, you're scooting over.
Okay.
Already?
Oh my god.
You're so fast.
Don't even have time to...
Oh god.
I'm just trying to blast you.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
What did I do?
How did I earn that?
Oh gosh.
Just gonna GT.
Come on.
So close.
Just one doggy.
Just one dog left.
No.
Chip him away.
Okay.
Alright, we got the dog.
Why did he give me robs?
Nobody else did.
Beowulf?
What's the orange one?
I don't think it's red or orange.
It's red and orange, right?
I don't know what orange is.
Yeah, red is Leviathan and I hate that one.
It's not bad.
It's just, you know...
Doppelganger?
Really?
You have to fight him again?
He even counts?
That guy.
I just fought him.
What are we looking at here?
26.
I can beat Beowulf with his own fists.
I don't even know where orange is.
This was...
Oh, never mind.
I don't think I went here.
What is this one?
That looks like my doppelganger.
Oh, I just went in a big old circle.
That's doppelganger.
Okay, so my intuition was correct.
Okay, maybe up here.
I just want to see what it looks like with the orange.
Hello.
I cannot
tell.
Then there's the horse.
The reaper miniboss?
No way.
It's just one of the scythe guys?
They are like, do you remember your trauma?
Okay, they thought it was difficult enough at the very beginning of the game that they...
That they actually included it here.
That's insane.
That's so funny.
They are like, yeah, we know that we fucked up.
We know.
We know that that mission was so hard.
Anyway, you made it here.
Anyway, you did it.
You're here.
You know?
How the hell did we do this?
Oh, I'm on gunslinger.
This one is not so badly...
Like, this one is a little bit more fresh in my mind at least.
And I have a double dash now too, which is kind of cool.
My dash did not...
Okay, I know everyone was like, you need to be more aggressive with him.
Ah, shoot.
Oh my god.
Double dash.
I think I basically do this.
Oh, I have... I do this until he like starts...
Oh, shoot.
Can I double?
Oh, I can.
Oh, that's so powerful.
Oh, I can just leap over his head.
Until he does the thing and then I stinger those.
Oh my god.
I just leap over his head.
That's so powerful.
Whatever works, I say.
Whatever works.
Oh, I didn't escape fast enough or far enough.
Oh my god.
I don't trust myself to switch between trickster and... You know what?
Oh no.
That's it.
I don't trust myself.
I'm just gonna keep... Okay, and then he turns into dog mode.
Where?
Okay, is it here?
Yeah.
Oh, I was not soon enough.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
Definitely screwed that up.
Wait, what?
How am I doing it wrong?
Guys?
Oh, it's sword master.
That's right.
That's okay.
I have to fight this guy again.
Is it here?
Ah, nope.
Nope.
I'll... I'll... Get me out.
Get me out, please.
Oh damn.
Oh god.
This is so messed up.
Okay, that was a big thing though to switch to the sword master.
Okay, thank you for the reminder, guys.
Okay, switch to sword master for that one part.
Okay, I think we can get him though.
I think we can get him though.
Like I said, he's a little bit more fresh in my mind to where I feel...
Oh wait, uh...
A little bit...
A little bit better about... I don't remember what the hell I...
I think I just kept blasting.
I say he's fresh in my mind and at first phase I'm like...
That's okay.
It works!
Yes!
Come
on, Biowoke.
One does need to get back into it.
So far, not so bad.
It's a little slow of a method.
It's a little slow of a method, but I'm... If you are a hare, I am the tortoise, okay?
Like, if you are... If you play like the hare, I play like the tortoise.
Oh, oh shoot.
No!
Pretty sure the rules are reversed in this case.
What do you mean?
The hare goes fast and the tortoise is slow and steady.
Don't you know animals?
Don't you know that turtles are slow and rabbits are fast?
Thank you for the superchat!
I don't know what it said.
I just see people responding to it.
Are
you gonna explode now?
Yeah.
And I'm just gonna keep on blasting, baby.
Oh no!
At least we got one.
Oh my gosh, I feel like I'm being too passive.
And if I'm saying that, you know it's a problem.
I only remember how to avoid him.
I don't remember how to fight him.
Oh shit.
Oh dang.
I thought I got out of the way.
Okay.
Oh no!
Oh my god, I can't get out.
Screw it.
Dang
it.
Oh, that's so messed up.
I jumped out of the way.
Come on.
Come on!
Alright, we're at phase three.
Hurry.
We have to save some DT for when he goes... Oh shit.
Shit.
Dang it.
Oh, that one always misses.
That's right.
What?!
Oh,
double dash.
Double dash.
We were doing so hot until we were not.
Oh gosh, double dash.
Double dash.
I got cornered into a wall, guys.
Wait.
Wait!
Oh okay.
This is it.
I can't even... It's not even letting me move.
It's not even letting me move.
Am I still a trickster?
Yes, I am.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Oh, I don't have enough DT.
This is it.
N.T.
The sword master move you have to use is sword throw, not stinger.
Oh, how do I do that again?
Oh, that is a thing I use, isn't it?
How do I do that again?
Help me.
File.
Which is high time.
Nope.
Not a million stabs.
RB forward A.
Oh, I was doing X.
Oh, it won't let me switch.
What's so annoying is it won't let me switch modes in here.
It won't let me do anything.
So if I want to practice, I can't.
They're like, no, you can't try it in here, you guys.
It's like, no, you're good enough, I guess.
She's the tortoise that's approaching.
Approaching.
She's still approaching.
Yeah, if I try to...
There
you go.
For everybody who needs the foolproof.
Trickster.
Oh, that was not good.
I overestimated a little bit.
Oh, oh, I'm not feeling it.
I'm not feeling it, you guys.
I'm not feeling it this round.
Oh, no.
Oh, I know.
Hold on.
I must time you out.
Sorry.
Don't tell me to be aggressive when I literally told you this is how I play.
Sorry, guys.
I'm kind of spicy today.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
I think I woke up on the wrong side of the bed.
It's like, how about you play in my style?
How about you play the game that I play?
Okie dokie.
I'm not usually this spicy, though.
I don't know what's wrong with me today.
It's not like anything bad happened.
I'm just feeling a little spicy.
Oh, shoot.
I did not realize I was against a wall.
Oh, this one is going so bad.
No, this one is going so bad.
I hate when it moves the camera like that.
I hate it.
No, it was even before Nevin.
I don't know.
Like, just today, I was like, oh my god, get me out of here.
Even today, just like, I was just kind of grumpy working on stuff.
I considered not streaming, but I thought I would be okay.
So, I apologize.
Oh my god, it doesn't help if I...
If I try to be aggressive and I can't even land a hit.
Is that phase two?
This one goes up.
Got it.
Oh, and my sword back.
Trickster, please.
Please.
I lost a lot of health just now.
No, screw it.
Screw it.
Eat it.
Goddamn.
Damn.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, the camera.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, camera.
Oh my god, oh my god, camera.
Oh, whoops, that's not what I meant to do, but it's okay.
I pressed jump, I did.
I can't see anything.
I need to really...
Okay, I need to have enough.
Okay, alright, we have enough DT.
Just in case he decides to go crazy.
Wait.
Nice.
This one goes up.
And I'll take that.
DT!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Grab the dwarves!
Okay, alright.
One, two...
Oh, okay, nevermind.
You went off script.
That's fine.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, I don't have enough.
Oh no, no!
No!
You bastard.
Oh come on, you just did that move!
You just did that move!
You just did that!
You can't!
You cheater!
Oh my god, please.
That's so cheating!
Why isn't there a cooldown?
Oh my god.
I thought he was gonna do the leap.
He's not consistent.
I think that's what is so annoying about this fight, is he's so inconsistent.
He doesn't like, run, run, jump, run, run, jump, run, run, jump.
You know, he's like, sometimes he's like, run, jump.
Sometimes he's run, run, run.
Sometimes he's run, jump, jump.
Like, he's just so annoying!
He saw you spamming range and said, that's a good idea.
Except my range doesn't do as much damage as his.
Oh gosh.
I don't think he shoots the feathers when you're too far.
Because I was very close to him when he shot it the second time.
When he shot it the second time and was spamming.
I don't know guys, how are we feeling?
I think I might try the tongue again.
Or whatever the hell that was.
The esophagus.
Oh...
It's sword master, right?
Or maybe not.
What was it?
Oh, we got it.
I don't remember the music being kinda cool like this.
Isn't he gonna launch a laser?
No?
Where's the laser?
Oh, here
it is.
Here's the laser!
You know what, screw it.
It's so gross!
What do I do with these?
Maybe I don't need to switch.
I tried to parry them, but I don't think it worked.
Hello!
No, this guy.
Oh, laser!
Oh my god, can you give me a...
I hate this game so much.
It doesn't give me any chance to react.
Like it doesn't let me...
Oh my god, it doesn't let me...
Fucking hell, it doesn't...
I'm like stuck in a corner.
And it doesn't let me do anything.
Oh my god.
Hey, chill.
Oh, no, not you.
Can you...
I don't care about you guys.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
Ah!
She's crashing out?
I've been crashing out.
I literally just ended up having a bad day.
We got so much closer with this one, so I think I'm just gonna go with this.
Honestly.
Alright.
Are you gonna do... Oh, no.
Big damage.
When are you gonna do the laser?
Not... Not yet.
Okay, I have to be attacking this thing again?
And then you'll be like, oh, I'm getting attacked.
Might as well do the laser.
No, okay, no laser.
I'm trying to pay attention.
To do the laser.
Can you guys leave me alone?
Oh, here he comes.
Oh, man, we didn't get a lot of DT that time.
Okay.
Alright, come back, you.
Mr. Squishy.
It's so disgusting.
What was the...
Gosh.
Maybe it was trickster?
Or...
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait!
Sword bastard.
Oh, and yeah.
Two on this.
And, oh.
Not good, not good, not good.
Leave me alone!
Leave me alone, you stupid skellies!
Whatever the hell you are.
You stomach parasites.
Alright, let's go fight the Grim Reaper again.
Let's go fight the Grim Reaper...
Again!
That one was so much faster than Beowulf.
Okay.
The orange one, right?
Is the Grim Reaper?
Oh, that's the horse.
I get so lost in here.
The devil has awakened in me.
Today I'm not a ghost.
Today I'm a demon.
Lucky, lucky.
Next to the horse.
But like, down here.
Right?
Or am I crazy?
Up here?
I can't remember.
This is me.
Here?
Next to the horse.
Not here?
Here?
Here!
Oh my god.
I can't believe we are back here!
Wow!
Oh my god.
We have everything we have now though.
We have...
We are stronger now.
We are back at this level, but we are different!
We are better!
We are stronger!
Oh, here it is.
Oh my god, it's here.
Oh, that didn't parry at all.
Oh, where'd you go?
Where'd you go?
Come here.
Yeah!
Oh shoot, I stopped.
I stopped attacking.
Parry!
Parry the platypus!
Just keep going.
Don't stop.
He's almost dead.
Sweet!
Showtime!
Oh my god, I got...
Oh
gosh, I keep trying to get out of the way.
I'm so bad.
Oh, here we go.
Devil trigger.
And then when I can attack him...
Oh, so close!
One more!
There we go!
Wow!
Yippee!
Oh, there's more.
Just kidding.
Yippee for two seconds!
Everybody get stinger!
You get stinger!
You get...
Again?
Was he there a second time before?
No, right?
I don't actually remember.
It's been like three years.
Oops, that's not what I meant to do.
No!
Oh god, I might die for real then.
Oh shit.
That's not what I meant to do.
Please give me some grub!
Oh shit!
I switched to sword master instead of jigsaw.
Oh, I don't think I'm gonna make it, you guys.
I don't think I'm gonna make it!
Oh my god!
Well, we have to.
We have to do it.
We've settled on this path.
I'm not gonna use a new... I'm not gonna use Nevin because...
I don't think this is a good time for me to learn a new weapon.
Considering I never used it before.
If I had been training with it this time, then I think it'd be different, but...
Why didn't you give me any grub, you cheap...
You cheapos!
You're so cheap!
You're all cheap!
Cheep cheep cheep cheep!
And he's here!
Oh my goodness.
Ow!
Okay.
Oh, he's not down?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Ah, shoot.
What's the point if I can't even dodge correctly?
I always just go the wrong way.
I never can get it correctly.
I never can predict which way he's gonna be at.
What's the point?
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Actually, I'm gonna save this.
Well, we'll get more.
No, I'm gonna save it since I think he... Oh, shoot.
Actually, no.
Never mind.
I can change my mind.
I changed my mind.
Oh, he's back?
Okay.
Oh, shit.
No!
Everyone's against me!
Oh, my trauma of having to redo this freaking battle so many times.
Oh, shoot.
No.
Oh my god.
Please.
Hmm?
I'm strategizing in my brain.
I'm trying to remember what I need to click before I go into the battle.
I'm not reading chat, but thank you.
Well, I am now.
Well...
Yeah, you get a time out for that.
For telling me what to do!
Don't say this will be the run!
That always jinxes me.
Oh god, there's so many of them.
No.
Yeah!
The music is so awesome and scary at the same time!
I'm trying to get rid of this guy.
Just so I can get him gone.
Okay.
Die already!
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
I think sword master might be... Well, at least if I have my air hike.
I was gonna try and...
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
Oh, shit.
The stinger.
Stinger, my beloved!
Jump!
Jump out of the way.
Oh my god, I thought I would get you.
Oh, not doing so hot.
Not doing so hot, guys.
Get his ass!
I can't tell if the mobs keep spawning or if I'm just not getting them fast enough before the other guy comes in, you know what I mean?
Oh god, he's already here!
Oh no, they're definitely... Wait, actually I can't tell.
Oh my god.
Maybe they're not respawning.
Oh, they are.
Or there's at least new guys.
There's new guys.
Okay, okay.
So we need to focus our efforts...
Oh, shit.
On... this guy.
No!
I got in my way!
Oh my god!
Please, camera, I can't see!
Please!
Jump!
I tried to jump out of the way.
Sometimes it works and sometimes... Oh my god, it doesn't.
Oh my god, please.
No!
I have to pee so bad!
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Oh,
shit.
Come on!
I got his ass.
Oh, we still have to fight you guys?
Okay.
Okay, that's so fair.
Sure.
Whatever.
Okay.
Yeah!
Alright, it was the strut instead.
That was the strut instead.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Bald.
Trying to compensate for something?
That should be my sword!
He's like, I ain't studying the blade.
Oh no!
Wait, does he actually get Sparda's armor?
Oh my god.
No way!
Oh no.
Oh no!
Sparda cosplay.
How long did this take us?
Let's see.
Two hours.
Holy hell.
Yeah, I gotta go to the bathroom.
Oh my god.
What's that?
Now we have two missions left.
Two left, I think.
B for bad level.
That's what I say.
Oh, he's just casually walking by her.
Wait!
Wake up lady!
She's right there!
Too bad you gave away your gun.
He has to use doors just like all normal people too.
Sparda is like you and me.
He also uses doors.
Ok, I gotta go pee so bad.
Hold on, I'll be right back.
Okie dokie, I'm back.
Mission 19.
Forces collide.
Topple the great beast with Faith's bullet.
Oh my god.
Welcome back, thank you!
Oh, these guys again.
Oh, ok, thanks for the warning.
Oh wait, no, no, there we go.
You guys are flames.
So I use ice.
Oh, I'm like sword master?
Chew on this!
Oh, oops.
Almost had a null.
Wait, can I have my robes?
Thank you.
It's cute!
Chew on this.
Nice.
It's cute!
Do I go in the mirror now, again?
Anything hidden in here?
Wait, are more things spawning?
No.
Wait, what did I just hear?
I'm like hearing things moaning and groaning.
Oh, it's just part of the ambiance.
This place is so freaky!
Wow, look at the tombstone.
Could be yours, could be mine.
Oh, again?
Oh, ok.
Am I not hitting them?
Am I not doing any damage?
Oh my god.
Hold on, I'm just trying to...
What the hell?
I can't tell if I'm doing this right.
I'm just trying, I guess.
Stop!
Oh!
Oh, we got him.
Nice.
Ish.
Wait.
Oh no.
We had them.
Oh, there's an even freakier guy.
Even freakier guy.
This one.
I'm looking.
Oh, here it is.
Oh my god.
Oh, my brain is starting to...
What the hell?
Every time I get close to it...
Oh, there we go.
I'm gonna die at this rate.
Come on!
Yeah!
Ok, I have to break all of them, I'm guessing.
Oh, no I don't.
Yippee!
Ok, that wasn't so bad.
Any hidden...
No?
Ok.
How's the game been?
I think today...
Oh my god.
It hasn't been so great, but it's ok.
Any... Well, no.
I was gonna say the first one, too.
The first time I played this game, too.
If anything was going to tilt me enough to never want to play the series again, it would've been today and the first time I played it.
Have our off days.
It just sucks that when you are online...
You're not allowed really to have an off day because then it seems like you're just not having fun and are miserable and stuff.
But that's ok.
It's not fun for people to watch you have an off day, you know what I mean?
And especially in games like this, I have to have a lot of patience because people try to give me advice.
And sometimes I'm like, yeah, this is advice!
And sometimes I'm like, ah, they're just backstabbing and it gets all frustrating for me.
Even though I know people just mean well.
So I try to have a level head about it.
As much as I can, even on my off days.
I disagree.
I enjoy frustrated ghost noises.
I think it's different when I'm frustrated and I'm like, ah, this is tricky.
And it's different, I think, when I'm frustrated and I'm just...
Pissy.
Samsara.
Sculpture symbolizing the time-space continuum.
Wow, we have something like that?
Use to restore order to time-space rifts.
Oh, we don't have any issues with that.
We don't have any time-space rifts.
Unless...
No.
You're doing really good, Mito.
Remember that we're happy when you're happy.
Thank you.
Oh, they're all gone.
The horse!
Yeah, the horse.
I can't believe I was just like, the horse is so easy, and then I died and gave up and never tried again.
I was like, you know what, I don't think I wanna play the horse.
Hello?
This way?
PTSD.
I think I did pretty alright with Beowulf trying again in the way that I did.
I think I did okay.
I gave it a couple shots.
It didn't work and then I left.
I'm gonna... The orb is so expensive.
I think I'm gonna get a porb.
They gave it a college try.
I did!
This is the door I go through, right?
Oh no.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, let me out.
Wait, hold on.
Oh god.
I'm trapped.
Wait, am I going the right way?
Wrong portal.
Okay.
Gosh, there's another one?
I didn't even notice it.
I thought I was backtracking.
I suppose I'm not.
Is that it?
That looks funky.
Over there?
Me and my mom are cheering you on with pizza.
I want pizza!
What kind of pizza?
Oh, I went the wrong way.
It's a porbel.
The porbel.
I'm starting to get hungry.
Is this the one?
But this is the one I went through before.
I just go through it again.
A little confusing game.
There we go.
Oh god, my eyes!
Okay.
I can't turn the camera all the way around?
Why not?
Why?
Okay.
This really doesn't say anything.
Oh, substance projects image and image punishes substance.
I didn't even need to read.
What do you say?
Kicking ass today, watching you girls play TMC has been an incredible journey.
Even with frustrations, you're still winning.
And I'll be the whole way cheering you on.
Thanks Sparky!
Doesn't that broken statue remind you of someone?
This?
Oh, whoops.
Sorry.
Virtual Ghost GF.
I would propose, but I'm not ready for that sort of commitment.
You're already asking for a whole lot.
Wait.
Did I go through it the wrong way again?
This again?
Oh, the gold statue.
Oh, I need to interact with it.
Hold on, I'll go do it.
The gold statue.
Okay.
I thought it looked a little out of place, but...
Hello?
Stop the vicious circle by bending time and space.
Looks like something can be inserted here.
Okay, we insert.
That was...
We broke the cycle.
We're no longer Homura Kemi.
Madoka, I'll save you.
Oh, end of the line.
It's looking real Kingdom Hearts here, guys.
Looking mighty Kingdom Hearts here.
Okay.
I already bought some.
Let's go.
Sparta.
Not Sparta.
You wish you were Sparta.
I can't understand your action.
Dante, I'm going to steal that one.
It's like a backed up toilet.
Enunciate your words, mister.
I'm glad Dante and I have the same look on our faces.
I hate that.
He literally turned into a genus.
The little...
Look, you see the gaping butthole.
Right there.
Forbidden Nirvana.
Okay.
I want to kill him with his daughter's weapon.
But it does nothing.
Okay.
Slugs!
Oh no, there are so many slugs!
There are so many slugs!
Oh my god.
What the hell is happening?
What the...
They all just chill and wait for me.
Is that you?
Is that your inhaler, mister?
What the...
Oh, is that his face?
Nasty!
Come here.
Come here, nasty.
Let's see if
I can punch him instead.
Nasty.
When I press jump, that's what you need to do.
Oh my god.
Please, just get rid of this guy.
You do more than just summon slugs.
Oops.
I
don't think I...
Oh my gosh.
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
Oh my god.
These guys are so obnoxious.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I don't know what's the best way to take care of them.
Slice and dice or...
Oh my god, they are so annoying.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's still a guy.
We're gonna chip at him away.
Like we always do.
Until I get more DT.
And then I can...
What the hell are...
Are those more slugs?
More slugs!
More, even more slugs!
Even more slugs!
Okay, that wasn't so bad.
There we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Let's punch him.
Gotta get our little RPG in first.
I'm punching him.
Oh, now I'm scared.
Scared to punch.
Scared to keep punching.
Okay.
Punch, punch, punch!
More slugs!
No,
I'm trying to lock on.
Oh my god.
Okay, I think we got him.
I'm gonna...
I don't know what's good for him.
I got you to half health!
What are you talking about?
My brother!
Oh my god.
Where are you?
I've come to retrieve my power.
I've always wanted Virgil as my brother.
He deserves to be our main vendor.
You're right.
He's wagging his finger at him.
Yeah, buddy.
Battle of brothers.
Oh my god!
Show Arkham the true power of the sons of Sparda!
Virgil follows Dante's lead but still spins off his own special style of ass kicking.
Press the A to call Virgil to your side.
Oh my god!
You cannot utilize demon form while fighting with Virgil.
Wait, what?
I can't double trigger?
Can I get like a... Can you... Oh my god, my brother.
Can he give me like a...
Give me a gore while I'm, you know, since I...
Oh god.
Why can't I double trigger?
Come on, I need you to... I need you to work.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Ah!
Shoot.
Oh, he killed him.
Maybe?
No.
No, he didn't.
Come on.
Can you do something?
Oh god.
I really need to heal though.
I really need to heal.
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
I wish he would like... I still attack.
Oh.
Oh, do I restart at the very beginning?
Oh, OK.
Well, now that I know that...
Now that we know that...
Now that we know that we can't heal...
Yeah, I wish he would like kind of do a little bit of anything while, you know...
And I feel a little bit better about this now.
Oh, he hits hard though.
Oh, he hits really hard.
Holy moly.
Oh gosh.
I don't know his like fighting at all.
He just like slams his hand and then he also shoots a thing.
What the hell is that?
Oh!
Oh, that's the thing that he shoots.
OK.
I got it.
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
I'll just stand here.
I'll spam.
Spam.
Oh god.
OK.
Maybe this one... I don't remember what I... I think it was this one that I used before that I was like...
Oh, this isn't so bad.
Come on.
Oh, nice.
We avoided that.
But then we got hit by his little tiny hand.
So nasty.
Oh my goodness.
Again?
Oh, we're not doing as well this time.
We're not doing as well this time, but that's OK.
Trying to decide if I want to use it or not.
I do have one holy water.
Save stars till you're close to phase two.
OK.
I'll just heal with these guys.
Oh god.
They're so nasty.
They're so awful.
Oh god.
I don't know if I'm close to phase two or not.
I feel like I might be.
But it's also hard to tell.
Oh my god.
He's going to shoot his nasty.
He's going to shoot it at me.
OK.
Now, definitely use it.
Huge.
OK.
Now, don't touch the devil star because we can't even use it.
Alright.
Nice.
Scum.
I
can use the small one too if I have to.
Come on.
Kill them.
Scum.
Call them what they are.
Die.
Keep killing them.
Keep killing them, Virgil.
Keep doing it.
Virgil, I need your help.
Oh my god.
Scum.
Nice.
Oh my god.
That's not good at all.
Come on, Virgil.
Virgil, I need you to hit.
I need you to hit too.
I need us to both hit.
Come on.
If I have to use another item, I will.
I will.
I'm not afraid to.
Scum.
Will the holy water work on him?
Vital S.
That's what I was thinking.
This tinier one.
Let's just take it.
It will.
I can't see.
Oh my god.
Hold on.
I'll use it.
Let's try it.
Item.
Holy water.
Use.
Oh my god.
It did mega damage.
Did you guys see that?
Oh my god.
We are so close.
Scum.
Come on.
Just kill.
Just take them out.
Scum.
There he is.
Come on.
Please.
So scary.
I got the first hit in.
This guy sucks.
Thanks Virgil.
Oh my god.
We traded swords through his body.
That's so... Oh my god.
That's so metal.
Take him out.
Eww.
His ugly face.
Oh my god.
See?
This is what it could have been with me and Lady.
Yeah.
Not very classy.
They are so smooth.
With every movement they do.
Their necklaces!
Who's gonna get the sword first?
Oh my god.
They defeated the ender dragon.
You the player.
Don't think I'll be scum any time of the day.
20 minutes.
Boss bonus.
Alright baby.
Final mission.
Give me all your energy.
I suppose.
Lady.
She's so chill.
Just walking up.
Sorry.
I have a pinched nerve in my shoulder.
So I'm like...
Yeah!
Kicked him right out of hell!
Wow.
You suck so much you got kicked out of hell.
My fave boss in the game.
Combo use doppelganger.
Oh.
I forgot about doppelganger.
How do I use it?
Nah.
Because you suck.
You suck.
Okay.
Neanderthal looking ass.
Get out of here.
This guy is just a cockroach.
He doesn't die.
I should call him Mitara.
Oh my god.
Don't ever call me that again.
My mother was the only one who could say my name.
Shoot me?
Can you shoot me?
Your own father?
What have I done wrong?
Even Horrocks Bard has sacrificed a woman so that he could become a legend.
I wish to be a god!
What have I done wrong?
And I sacrificed one miserable human being for that reason.
Miserable?
That is all.
Was that really so?
I know.
Yeah.
I'd argue quite a bit wrong buddy.
I think you kind of really messed up him.
He's more than just a silly guy.
Look it.
He's got bad hemorrhoids.
Mary died a long time ago.
My name is Lady.
She took Lady!
Goodbye father.
What a pathetic, pathetic guy.
His last words were no.
What a pathetic guy.
Oh my god.
Imagine your last words being something really stupid.
Like spaghetti or something.
That would be so silly.
Rip Bozo!
She's lamowing.
She's ruffling right now.
She's rolling on the floor laughing.
She thought he's through.
Thanks for 9 months.
Lady.
I like Lady.
Oh I saw the 20.
I saw the 20 in the sky.
I saw it.
20 in the clouds.
Screaming souls.
Cast off your pride and embrace your fate.
Alright guys.
Let's go.
Is there anything I should buy before we go?
Anymore items or anything like that?
Or you think I'll be okay?
I have 30,000.
Heals for sure.
You guys are scaring me.
Spaghetti-chan would be so upset.
You said that.
Lot of heals.
Okay.
Do you think like 4 is enough?
5.
Okay we'll get 5 heals.
I'll even get some small ones.
A gorb.
Oh I didn't think about that.
Uh...
Ripperoni.
I still have 2 devil stars.
He's too fast.
He's too cool.
His little smirk.
No!
Yeah!
Blow the bank in this way.
Why are you so greedy?
Virgil, come on.
You are like papa.
You will never be like papa.
His soul.
This is soul.
My soul is saying it wants to stop you!
It wants to stop you!
You got all the...
You got all the dominant genes.
Oh gosh.
Unsacred Hellgate.
Hey Virgil!
If I walk this way and you walk that way...
Oh god.
I'm on trickster.
Okay.
We've done this fight before.
Oh my god.
Wait where am I?
Okay.
I need the air hike.
Scum!
We got one measly hidden.
What the hell is that?!
Oh no way.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm gonna be aggressive for this fight.
A little bit.
Can he also devil trigger?
No, don't do that.
Don't do that.
Scum.
Oh he can.
Okay.
He can.
Understood.
Oh my god.
Yes he can.
Why am I even trying to touch him in this mode?
Are we like flowing down the river?
If we touch the end we die?
He's healing.
I know.
Shit man.
Oh my gosh.
How does he get me so...
Gosh.
Come here.
Dang.
He heals a lot too.
This guy is seriously... He seriously cheats.
Okay.
Someone said do doppelganger.
How do I do this?
Wait.
Hold on.
I'm trying to figure out this new move I just got.
How do I use it?
Doppelganger.
Oh it's DT?
No it's not.
I got one guide.
Lock on A.
Oh you need DT.
Hold on.
I'm gonna go time that guy out.
You!
Where are you?
Actually I don't know who said it first.
Don't tell me when to DT you guys.
Don't tell me when to DT.
Okay.
Oh I forgot.
How do I avoid you?
Oh my god.
This damn homing.
Oh shit.
He's gonna be like full health after this.
Oh my god.
So I need to lock on A when I have DT.
Wait.
Hold on.
So now I'm doing double damage?
Is that what's happening?
I'm about to die.
Yeah there we go.
Shooting will counter the sword throw.
I see.
Oh my god.
Guys, is there a way to cheese this?
It's just combo after combo.
Oh my god.
Holy water spam.
You guys told me to buy heals at holy water.
Doppelganger just makes a clone that will mimic your movement with a slight delayed combo.
It's not really good compared to even Quicksilver.
Hold on.
Dante in the first Virgil fight.
Father, I don't have a father.
I just don't like you.
Dante in final Virgil fight.
We are the sons of Sparda.
I know, right?
This is what we call character development.
How did I get... How did I even... How was I... I don't know how I managed to attack him before.
We're both in double trigger now.
Until... Not anymore.
How did I... How did I...
Scum.
Ouch.
God.
Oh, okay.
It did.
Oh, ouch.
Ouch.
I didn't realize what he was doing.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna punch you.
I'm gonna punch you in the face.
I'm gonna...
Never mind.
You're gonna stab me in the stomach.
It was literally the cutscene.
We are literally...
Guys, I don't know about this one.
I'm truly honest.
You know how some fights are tough and you're just like, I think I can get the hang of this eventually.
You bastard.
You knew I was doing that.
Oh, wait.
I switched to Beowulf.
Can you parry with Beowulf?
I can't... Guys.
Guys, I don't know about this fight.
I don't know.
I don't know about this one.
Oh shit.
No!
Why are you saying that?
I'm so afraid for phase 2.
Here it is.
My death!
Oh...
What the hell?
When did he do that?
He's standing there menacingly.
Ah, the water!
The hell?
Okay, the shooting does not...
The shooting doesn't do as much as I would have liked it to.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is it.
I shot too late!
I shot as soon as he threw it!
The music is just a little bit like Sephiroth's theme.
So what?
ABS?
Always be shooting?
Ouch.
Got
the combo on him, baby!
Oh, I stopped shooting, but not in time.
Gotta be so soon.
Oh no, again?
Already?
Oh my god!
Ah...
Anime finish for real.
Oh, come on!
Come on!
I hate you so much.
Virgil, we were so cool together.
What happened?
Why do you get to hit me and I don't get to hit you?
Unfair.
I feel like he is about to throw the sword.
Yep, I knew it.
Oh my god!
No!
Fine!
Me too!
Where are you?
Where did you go?
Yeah, where did you go?
Come here!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Are you gonna shoot it?
Yep.
I did not even see you come over here.
What are you gonna do?
Oh my god!
Oh shit.
I can't.
Oh, I don't have enough DT and I got caught in his combo loop.
No!
Oh god.
Oh no!
Ok, now I can.
Oh my god.
Scum!
Now!
Oh, now you are motivated.
Ok, buddy.
Ok, guy.
Damn it.
This guy sucks so bad.
Oh guys, I don't know what to say.
Oh, there we go.
Hmm.
It's really easy to get him after that.
Oh!
Oh my god, why did I shoot?
I'm a big old dummy.
Oh shit.
Oh, it's so scary being close to him.
Damn it!
Oh my god!
We are such brothers.
Scum!
Oh my god!
He can get a hit, but not me!
Hardest boss in all DFC games?
Five hours?!
I wanna go home.
I don't wanna play anymore.
Can I just watch a cutscene and say I did it?
God.
Good lord.
I can't even get him to halfway health.
What is this?
How do you dodge that?
Maybe the double...
No, not even with that.
Unless I just stand there and time it correctly.
Let me see.
I can barely get a hit into him though.
Oh shit.
At least it doesn't do a ton of damage.
Too late.
Scum!
Why do you also have the double trigger at the same time as me, you copycat?
You're a copycat, you know that?
Oh my
god, even when I dodge that way...
This guy is impossible!
This might be fun.
I messed up.
Oh my god.
Damn it.
Here we go, we're dead.
I couldn't get out.
I couldn't get out of the cycle.
I got trapped.
I couldn't move.
I kind of want to only use the vital scars once...
I don't have scars from this battle for real.
But once I learn his patterns a little bit more.
Once I feel a little bit more confident.
See, I get trapped into stuff like this.
What's the point of me healing if I'm just going to get trapped in it again, you know what I mean?
I don't know how to avoid that.
That, I don't know how to avoid that.
Because I even tried, I did like...
Oh my god, I did this and I couldn't get out of it.
Because he followed me.
I'm too slow.
Everything sucks by jumping.
Yeah, I definitely did that.
Yeah, I did that and he still got me.
Yeah, I did that.
I don't think it's very helpful if you just say, you know, you just jump.
Because it's, you know what I mean?
I have to do that, but it's like the timing of it all is just...
I'm so angry right now.
And then you can't get out of that.
That is so...
This is the worst combo to be stuck in.
Because how, you can't get out of it.
You just have to find yourself not in it.
Or else...
Or else you...
Oh my god.
Sorry, I'm like not really paying attention anymore, so...
I'm not really like fighting at the moment.
Kind of taking a break, but I'm mashing buttons as I do.
We can...
If I end, we could buy the holy water instead, maybe.
Jump away as soon as he lands, double jump.
Let me try one more time.
Wrong one.
I thought he was throwing it.
God damn!
Almost.
I thought I was stingering.
Oh, I'm on the wrong weapon!
Yeah, you get to hit me and I don't.
It's so unfair, you little bitch.
Fuck you.
You are so annoying.
Fuck you, Virgil!
Your nasal stupid ass voice.
I get a hit and he immediately...
I get a hit and he immediately combos me.
That's impossible.
Fuck you.
I always forget he does the jump.
The land, and then he...
And then he does a second move after it, so I'm not safe to go in.
Just yet!
Oh, wrong one.
And then he does another one!
And I have to jump out of... Yeah.
I hate this game.
If I use my items though, I'll lose them.
If I use my items, I'll lose them.
No, I have no money to buy more.
I have no more money to buy more.
Hold on.
I've never seen that.
That's so funny.
Rest in peace.
More like rest in piss.
Stupid ass game.
This one.
What do I have?
Let's see.
Holy water is so expensive!
I can only buy two.
I don't think it's worth it then.
How much is the gorb?
Gorbs are also so expensive.
I would only be able to buy two.
Anyway.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Get me out of here!
I'll just reload.
I'll just reload!
Yikes.
That did not do as much as I thought it would.
That kind of sucked.
That's kind of not great.
Oh, he's also a devil tricker.
Nah, it's not really worth it I think.
I'll try again.
How does it work when he's...
What the?
Did it do any damage?
Or am I just silly?
It did?
Okay.
I didn't see.
No!
Oh my god.
I hate when it...
Now I'm hollowing.
I'm gonna jump out of your stupid ass combo.
Ugh.
Oh shit.
Had a feeling he would.
Not yet.
Okay.
Sorry.
I'm gathering my senses.
Trickster, air dash.
Wait, with trickster you can air dash so you can move out of the way faster.
Also dashing to the side a bit better to dodge.
Yeah, I know I can air dash.
Sometimes it wouldn't work.
That's probably just a skill issue.
Sorry for backseating.
It's okay.
Thanks for apologizing.
So just run?
Just run?
Should I devil trigger for this?
Sorry.
Oh gosh.
I'm scared.
I'm scared because I don't know what this is and I'm doing so well.
DT ride.
Okay.
Oh shit.
What the hell is this?
Okay.
Triggered again.
Okay, me too.
Me too, me too.
Shit.
No!
Oh my god.
Use item.
You guys don't have to tell me twice.
What is this?
Spam.
Oh, is this it?
Is this where I just...
Oh god.
Okay.
I didn't need to devil trigger for that.
Okay, maybe I didn't.
Oh my god!
We did it!
Holy water.
Oh my god, it was the triple combo.
The holy water, the devil star, the vital star, everything.
I needed it all.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna take a cough drop.
Thank you.
There's no phase two, right?
That's it, right?
Oh my god.
I wish... No.
Don't say that!
There
are five phases.
Imagine if everyone else was gaslighting me and that one person was correct.
Oh, Virgil, with your nasty gloves.
Why are they skin colored?
They're so horrible.
They look like you have wrinkly old hands.
Pick me!
Thank you for that!
I'm super!
I feel so fulfilled.
I'm staying.
This place is our father's home.
Snake!
Oh my god.
Shoot him!
Just like with Ocelot.
Our brother.
Our brother, Virgil, no!
He left us the sword.
He was even smiling as he fell.
He's so sad.
Oh, our brother.
The sword is what becomes the Sparta sword in one.
Yeah, I think some people said that earlier.
For real.
Yeah, I was on loan.
It was not for keepies.
Ladies fun.
Then she got what she wanted.
She got to kill her dad.
And, you know, we took care of the hard part.
And now the city is destroyed.
There's like a little car in the building.
We should be fine.
Whatever.
The rest of the population...
It's only the rain.
Let me see his crying...
Let me see his crying face.
Let me see him cry like a baby.
Maybe somewhere out there even the devil may cry when he loses a loved one.
Don't you think?
Maybe.
He said the title.
By the way...
No way.
Never a moment's rest.
We are on clean up duty.
Bring it on baby!
Except not for me.
Ebony and Ivory baby!
Oh, I'm still going.
Oh my god.
Interactive.
Interactive credit scene.
Let's go!
And we are fighting with lady!
Yeah!
OK.
I know I said I hate this game a million times, but it was actually pretty fun.
That's right.
What was it?
Hit.
I can also shoot.
Oh, she got it.
She took my kill.
Oh my god.
This is crazy.
Can you even get hurt in this fight?
Is it just punching and kicking and everything?
It's what everybody wants.
You cannot hurt me.
Dummy!
I'm too strong now!
This is the game on easy mode.
And I didn't play it on easy mode.
Aren't you guys proud of me?
I played this game on normal.
And it's such a difficult game.
Are you proud of me?
Praise me!
Praise me mode!
Oh wait.
Oh.
I can change.
It just doesn't show the interface.
Let's finish with a rebellion.
Since that's our baby.
Oh wait.
There we go.
Shield time!
Oh.
I just... I don't know why I did that.
There we go.
OK.
And yeah!
80?
81?
Can we get to 100 before the credits end?
Die?
Yeah.
Nice.
Nice!
Come on!
Special thanks!
Oh god!
100!
90!
94!
We are almost there!
97!
Oh my god.
My trauma.
This is so evil.
This is the 99th.
Oh my god.
No way.
For
me!
So close.
We were so close.
He cleans up so nice.
Nice.
Thanks for playing DMC3 and congratulations on making it to the credits.
Thank you!
What?
What's that?
Oh mom!
Oh my god.
Devil May Cry baby!
Crazy!
He's so stylish.
I know, right?
Wow guys.
I only beat Virgil in 4 minutes.
What's wrong with you guys?
It took me 4 minutes to beat Virgil.
Why did it take you guys so long?
Oh my god.
First try.
I know, right?
Look at all the items I used.
Put me down to a D.
Oh my gosh.
We hit every rank.
A, B, C, D.
Wait.
S, A, B, C, D.
We got every single rank you could get in this one.
Imagine how salty Virgil must feel.
All those fancy sword moves and Dante just punched him in the gut over and over again.
I know, right?
Congratulations on beating 3 minutes.
Also, remember Raiden in MGS2?
We're gonna have that situation again in DMC4.
Don't worry.
This is not a spoiler.
Wait.
People didn't think that Dante was very cool?
Or is it that you thought you were gonna play as Dante and then you play as someone else?
Oh wait.
No.
MGS4.
Oh.
It is a spoiler though.
I guess it depends on what you define as a spoiler.
Maybe.
Anyway.
A.
I graduated school with these grades.
I'm not a straight A student.
In fact, I never even got a single A.
But...
But that doesn't matter.
C's get degrees.
Congratulations.
I do hate being considered normal.
Look at Beowulf right there.
Right in the center.
Agni and Rudra too.
Look at everybody.
Oh my gosh.
It's our star studded cast.
I kind of want to print this out and give it as a valentine's day card.
Why does it have that kind of energy?
I feel like if I were in grade school and I played this game...
I would have taken a picture of this and I would have passed this out as a valentine's day something.
Congrats on beating the game and you kicked butt today.
Thank you.
I do want to apologize again about me being so legitimately salty in the middle of the stream.
But I do feel better now.
I'm really sorry you guys.
I love this picture.
Hold on.
I need to screenshot this right now.
El gato.
Screenshot.
Oh wait.
I want to be in the picture.
I want to be in here.
Let me put my arms up.
I do hate being considered normal.
Oh yeah.
Next to Virgil.
How tall is he?
Maybe like here.
Oh yeah.
I do hate being... I do hate being considered normal.
I kind of want to be on top of Beowulf or next to Beowulf.
I'll be on top of Rudra, Agnia, whichever that one is.
Look at me I'm Beowulf.
Hey Beowulf.
I kind of come to love Beowulf so much.
I kind of come to love him.
Again.
Wait.
Let me take a picture.
Hold on.
I'm going to get rid of you guys.
Let me take a picture.
I'll go down here too.
One more picture.
Just to make sure I got it.
OK.
Screenshot.
Nice.
Yay!
I love this picture so much.
Hard mode now selectable.
Gallery mode now selectable.
Virgil is now selectable.
New costume has been added.
Movies have been added.
Illustrations have been added.
Save.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
I just noticed the key visual of lady looks so good.
We found this year's Wisp Christmas card.
Beowulf has that ugly dog energy.
Yeah, maybe that's it.
Text on this Valentine's Day card.
You're my motivation.
That's so good!
That's so good.
Wow.
What's in the gallery?
Concept art.
Bold!
What else we got?
Oh.
Wow.
Oh my god.
Emo.
You can make like a Dante Vtuber out of this.
Wow!
Oh my god!
Devil Trigger.
I would want my Devil Trigger to look a little bit more mech.
I think.
I know that's not really the point of it, but...
I'm so excited for when you start DMC4 and 5 and find out that Redacted is Redacted and then you Redacted is Redacted.
Yeah!
Can't wait for all the Redactedness.
Oh, wow.
So many Virgils.
Virgil with a scarf?
Oh my god.
We were deprived.
Look, his gloves aren't flesh colored here.
Wow!
Oh my goodness.
This driver's license photo.
Lady!
God, she has a teeny tiny head.
I like that they made her hair a little bit longer.
Oh, Vulcan.
This guy.
Completely forgot he was a thing.
Oh, banning my existence.
Oh!
Is that what they look like?
They just look like statues and then they open up.
I didn't know that.
I've only just seen them as the eyes.
I never realized they were actually just muscular statue men.
They have an eight pack.
This sniper has an eight pack.
Oh my god.
He could have just beat me up.
Oh, Cerberus.
I like Cerberus a lot too.
Wait, I didn't see Cerberus in our picture.
Did they always not have heads?
Oh, I thought that they always had a head.
Oh their head is on the sword.
Wow, this feels very Warhammer.
Second floor, third floor, fourth floor.
Are you enjoying yourself?
Sugar.
Oh, this is a great visual.
Wow, this is a great visual.
Oh my gosh, I want to buy an art book now.
If you get to a hundred, you get a secret ending?
No way, really?
I was so close.
Are you one guying me, Brandon?
Oh, this is a great picture too.
Oh, we got all the pictures.
Promotional video!
E3.
Oh, it's true?
It's real?
Dang it.
Small secret scene.
Is it about... Is it a show like Virgil doing something?
Dang, that's so annoying.
Kind of sad we don't have E3's anymore, right?
AMC3 manga kind of implies Lady is still a schoolgirl and just modified her uniform for combat.
That's crazy!
I feel like now we only see things either in directs or the game awards.
There's one other event.
I can't remember.
Oh, yeah.
TGS?
No, true, true, true.
TGS.
I was thinking a western event.
Dante!
Oh my god, yes!
I love seeing sassy Dante.
Everyone probably saw this after DMC2 and was just like...
Look at him!
He's emoting!
Oh my god.
I can see!
See!
I
fought those guys.
Fought that guy.
I fought that guy.
Oh, yeah.
We were there.
Aerial rave!
Oh, yeah!
Fireworks!
Drive!
I never did that.
God, trailer Dante is so cool.
I'm so lame!
What the...
It looks so much like Raiden there.
It's scary.
Oh, that was cinema.
Cinema!
That was so peak.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
The song is called Devil's Never Cry and it's peak edge.
Crazy gameplay video.
This video features some of the craziest Devil's Never Cry gameplay ever?
That's a real wolf.
I kicked...
Oh, yeah!
Take them both down, baby!
That's what I did.
Yeah!
Kick them!
Kick them while they're down and while they're up too.
Oh, my eyes.
Oh my god.
Imagine playing DMC2 back in the day being disappointed thinking I'll never come back and then see this.
One of the rare times that a game could come back after a terrible sequel.
I can imagine it being so hype.
Oh, I would have just run away from that room.
Oh my god, I can hear him saying it.
I can hear...
I heard his voice.
Um, excuse me?
What the hell was that?
Quicksilver.
I never use that.
Wow, clear bonus art!
Oh, we have...
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, we have one!
You guys, we have one that is textless!
So you can actually make a Valentine with it.
Valentine's Day is coming up!
It's in literally less than a month.
Which, I have some stuff on Valentine's Day.
Actually, I have multiple things on Valentine's Day.
I'm gonna hint at something else since you stayed for...
Since first you watched me play Devil May Cry all the way to the very end and then also...
Since I was a little stinker today.
If you are going to HoloFest, there might be some cool things to check out.
HoloExpo, that's what I meant.
Not there, but...
Yeah, maybe keep a day open on your schedule.
That's all I'll say.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
If you wanted to watch the Devil May Cry anime on your free time...
Since it released before DMC4 and is canon set between 1 and 2.
Oh yeah, now I can finally watch that, right?
What else we got?
The logo 15 million times.
Oh, these are...
Oh, I just realized because we haven't unlocked them yet.
That's so funny.
No, ours is peak.
This is peak.
This is the best one.
This is the best one we could've unlocked.
This is actually...
Beowulf looks so goofy.
I love it.
This is the best one.
It's so good.
You have the king.
You have the horse.
You have the giant whale in the background.
You have Cerberus.
You have the big glob man.
It's so good.
You beat the hardest one.
Don't worry.
DMC4 is easier and has some fun new stuff.
Oh, and DMC isn't actually a bad game.
It's an unintentional comedy.
No, it's amazing.
I don't think it's even comedy at all.
It's so good.
Oh my god.
OK.
I can't wait to start DMC4.
If this was the hardest one then...
We made it.
We cleared it.
We did it.
Exiting the screen without save.
Oh, we did save.
We did save.
And I did it all on normal.
I am not...
Hello?
Wait, we could have changed this the entire time.
Look, he looks like such a nice boy.
This though?
Excuse me.
Hello?
Oh, I unlocked this.
Look at him here.
You could take that guy to your parents.
Not this guy.
After you take him to your parents.
Give Virgil a test drive.
Is everything unlocked from the beginning?
I think I am hungry.
So, I think...
I think maybe sometime...
Maybe if I am just like... I don't know what to do.
Maybe we can do like... I play Virgil as long as I can go...
In one sitting.
Kind of deal.
We will see how far can I get through the game as Virgil.
Or like, maybe also give myself a time limit.
How far can I get through the game in like 10 hours or something as Virgil.
Kind of dealio.
Very good idea.
But I am hungry.
So, I am going to go eat dinner.
And thank you guys for hanging out with me.
We beat two games this week.
Actually three.
Because I guess you can count me side.
So we beat Indiana Jones, me side and this game.
Tomorrow we start Metal Gear Solid 4.
And yeah.
Otsuminto everybody.
The chat already told you when the game first released they bumped up the difficulty by one level.
So normal was actually hard.
I am a gamer.
You won't catch me playing games on hard very often.
But no, I don't think anybody told me that.
But they did say that this game was pretty difficult.
Oh they fixed that for special edition?
Let me have the win.
Otsuminto everybody.
Thank you.
Bye.
Maybe I am in series.
Once we are done with Devil May Cry.
I am too emo.
I don't smile.
Shadow Generations.
Oh my god.
I kind of want to
play.
I was talking to Doki the other night and she was talking about the...
She was like, look the Hello Kitty DLC for Minecraft.
And I was like...
I was like, oh yeah.
She didn't realize that those kinds of modes have all new gameplay.
I played the Sonic Minecraft a little bit before.
So...
I am
going to go.
Yeah, before the song loops.